what is up
fam what is happening welcome to the
second
calabasas fight companion i'm here with
the crew
i am with the crew to my left is mark
the body harley
best body uh i'll say in the world dude
i've had a few drinks what i'll say in
the world zoo if there's another one
dude yeah
best buddy zoo culture by far the
perennial
superstar over there coming off a huge
win after a two-year layoff
i was so happy for even though cory's my
boy uh i was so happy for you man tj
dillashaw over there man
looking fresh too man thanks man yeah it
does your face is
i mean you're good you look fast your
face was up good this knee that's uh
gonna take a while yeah your leg is your
leg did fall off and then we got
josh thompson here the voice of bellator
the man the legend
mma royalty over there also won half a
weighing in podcast hey man we try to do
our best with that show it's doing well
right we're picking it up yeah you guys
are doing well man
yeah i feel like we're good i appreciate
it thank you we're all fans here
uh before we get started man we have a
bunch of smooth operators around the
table tonight as you can see
and that is thanks to manscape the
official electric trimmer of the ufc
so we know we got the viewers from
around the galaxy i wish they didn't say
that whatever
and your balls are pube free it's an out
of this world experience
so get your rocket ready like jeff bezos
for takeoff with manscaped and their new
lawnmower 4.0 join the 2 million men
worldwide who trusted manscape
and trim with confidence no knicks no
worries get
ready for your nuts to be smooth
all the thick boys tonight get 20 off
and free shipping with the code cfc
again that's code cfc manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code cfc manscape.com
we got the link in code in the bio let's
get to work man so we got the
main event of the prelims on right now
uh
bobby green versus
is a nightmare yeah if you know if
you're familiar with this dude he is a
technician
although tonight we said this before we
went on air i think he's reading his
newspaper clippings because
i haven't seen him fight like this i
haven't seen that that flashiness that's
that
that type of like disrespect in the cage
yet from him i mean wrong he's he's
nasty good i believe he's one of the
head coaches at tiger muay thai he was
out there in thailand
for a while there he's phenomenal
kickboxing man
a lot of skill i'm surprised bobby
didn't start wrestling a little bit more
yeah they supposedly they can't you know
sean shelby couldn't find a guy to fight
fazeev like you just kind of i don't
doubt it no bobby green was like all
right
they're like really okay bobby's a stud
man
tj how's the so the leg surgery went
well
yeah i just had surgery on thursday
which i can't believe you're here
because i was like dude don't worry
about doing the fight
you're not kidding me i'll be there i
was like hell yeah getting out of the
house bro i've been sitting on the couch
uh playing a little bit too many video
games watching tv yeah you know what i
mean saying
how's the crib yeah watch some fights
with some good company you know
you know so let's talk about that baby
face though look at that baby face
you clean up well wife made me grow the
beard out so i don't look so young it
looks good though the scar tissues all
look like you gotta it's almost cleaned
up
pretty quick man my face was up quick i
had 24 stitches in there
um i had four cuts in
four months so this eye eyes that cut
was bad man
that was bad and like big john said it
that he was like
it's not like he was just like across
one plane it was like across multiple
muscles and he goes across here too
yeah dude so i thought they were going
to stop to be honest because
probably worse spot to get kind of i
thought they're gonna stop the fight and
not to mention
you you blew your leg out yeah you know
what i'm saying like
you got a cut you got one leg yeah and
i'm you know all within like a minute
one of his coaches lisa bowling who's
one of my best friends who's my head
coach
me and him are texting during the whole
fight i'm like dude he's doing this on
one leg
yeah which were you thinking about more
money for sure oh really yeah did you
know it was blown out 100
right away so it was like the last 10
seconds of the round
last 30 the last 30 seconds around i was
in like a like a lazy leg lock the guy
like he had we're in the 50 50 position
i was completely out of it
but i was just kind of like chilling you
know i knew i won the rounds was like
[ __ ]
sit on top let the round finish out but
then he turned and started trying to
punch
me i was like all right [ __ ] so i came
back in my own ground and pound right
yep
and so i like came in hard on my own leg
and started ground and pounding
and didn't get me from the leg lock was
when we got into a scramble and he tried
getting back to his feet and i tried
standing on top so i cleaned my chest
over my
body at the same time i need my lcl just
went
pow and i hit it right away wow dude it
was like i'm super surprised
he didn't hear to feel it because i mean
i know i even heard it when it happened
um so i knew that i was like as soon as
round was over i went back to my corner
i sat down i was like dude my knees
[ __ ]
you said that to your coach instantly
that's the first thing i said they
bleeped it out on tv because it's espn
and i said because i said [ __ ]
definitely wish we heard that i was like
mine's like my knees [ __ ]
you could tell like you i mean there's
nothing as tough as you are there's
nothing you can do
like me it's not i saw i saw him looking
to the corner i was like oh that he has
like a 50 50 like you said with a
reverse hill hook
yeah he didn't have like he didn't have
it locked all the way up he just kind of
had it yeah i mean
so it wasn't when he had the like law
cause actually when he let go of it
and he tried scrambling up and he like
threw his legs down so he like hip
thrust into it
and i tried staying on top at the same
time and it's when the lcl just went out
to the side
and was it only the lcl that blew out no
i had a medial
meniscus buckle handle tear uh lateral
meniscus tear and a pcl tear
that sounds horrible yeah almost
everything i'm just glad it was an acl
like i
actually am happy with the results would
have been trouble could have been nine
months dude yeah you know like i'm
looking at a three month recovery right
now until i can get back to good
training
fight for the title beginning next year
but it's not it's not i don't mean to
interrupt you it's
like you know it's not terrible because
you're not dude you're not finding
next year anyways no matter what even if
you were injury-free
exactly fighting for the title next like
the only thing that sucks is going on
vacation camping around or you know
like that but that's why i got little
rascals yeah
roll around on a little scooter or
something like the fat girl at
disneyland
oh yeah eating a corn dog painkillers
which is cool
that's always fun right yeah was there a
moment during the fight where you're
like i'm gonna have to stop or at any
point like did the pain get bad
i thought they were gonna stop you're
such a goddamn savage no you beat
corey sanhagen on with one eye and one
leg this only reason why i'm somewhat
happy with the performance i go back and
watch it and i obviously was like oh my
gosh
before that i watched the fight i was
like dude [ __ ] i was so sloppy i let it
i kept it way too close which if i was
close but when i go back and watch it i
definitely won the fight i agree
you know um and i know there was a a
close fight because he did damage but
you gotta remember the
rounds he did his damage in he won yeah
he run like those two rounds
damaging one of them was even close you
know i almost i'm i'm biased
i'm gonna give myself four rounds right
yeah but those two rounds that he won is
when he did most of his damage in it
second and fourth the second round for
sure i came out for flat footed not a
10-8 round though
no no no no because i had i'd take down
i actually thought that too i was like
there was a chance they could have given
him a 10-8 round i was thinking about
that that's the only thing that's the
only reason i'm saying that because
judges yeah
idiots so i was like i don't think so
though i came again i gave him the
second and the fourth
yeah i came up super flat footed on the
second because i was so worried about my
knee when i came out
he had one liked it flat footed yeah
exactly super flat i mean i'm i'm a
motion kind of guy
i'm gonna track you down i could be
honest i thought you were so [ __ ] yeah
i was like
i'm like man if his legs that bad i hope
they stop it due to the cut man
i don't respect him right yeah yeah i
mean i guess frustrated
um i don't have time to be frustrated
right
that's the that's the mentality of the
champion you know what i'm saying like
one eye one leg
i just feel like there was moments where
i was like another fighter would have
like mentally thrown in the towel 100
yes sometimes but there was a lot of
stuff i
just wrote him without just the knee oh
yeah it's like the i don't see them
enough yeah the higher just they'll get
into a fetal position
did you did you feel any uh you know
because dominic cruz doesn't believe in
ring rush some guys don't i i think it's
real but no
definitely listen to donald cruz not me
did you did you feel any ring rust
i think it's more mental right like it
could definitely be there if you want to
give yourself that excuse
um and i just want to not have any i
doubt in my mind going into that fight
the only thing is timing you know what
yeah
if that was the one thing i was gonna
say so like look i thought you looked on
point i said but i felt like you were
you're only throwing ones and twos where
before you were a combination fighter
you're throwing threes and fours
finishing with a kick to the head you
know whatever was
i always felt that that was like your
whole mmo before yeah so then getting
back into it you were throwing a lot of
ones and twos
occasional three but you weren't putting
it you weren't putting it all together
together
yeah it could be it could yeah very well
could be something
and he's moving right like he's got very
i already knew going to the fight it was
gonna be a frustrating thing he had a
great movement
he's gonna be hard to hit and so and
then i when i busted my knee i couldn't
cover the ground
i had to keep hitting switches to try to
cover the ground you know i had to come
out southpaw
i had to fight completely different cut
them off right and like that's why in
dude if i if i would have both my legs
those takedowns when i had his back
would have been so much
like i tried to lift in the second round
after i took his back and my knee just
buckled and i was like [ __ ] man yeah
that's the other thing is he kept doing
that granby roll and giving you his back
and i'm like well that's control
when you're there like you weren't
finished take down because your leg yeah
but you that's just that's that's
control man but a lot of what i talked
with big john about on our show is the
rule system
and so in terms of the scoring the
control is valued at the least
in terms of like the possession and
there's the damage in that round
it's still value but it's like here but
if the damage is here but if damage is
here
the damage here and actually trying to
finish the fight though
is isn't like here if we don't even get
to that next category for sure so what
they do is they don't even actually
judge that but but they can't if they
can't if they can't say all right well
it's round two you can right but
like one three and five if you're trying
to figure out right damage pretty
similar
you know then auction controls right
yeah but then you can get to control
yeah yeah and that was tj all day yeah
yeah that's why you but normally when
they get to that though from what i
understand from talking with john about
it all is that it normally gets down to
when it gets to the damage and they both
have had damage and you both have had
like a little bit of uh submission
attempts or knock
out a chance to finish light they don't
even get to control because it really
comes out of who did the most damage and
that kind of rules the round
so the damage rolls around and don't
even get to the control position
scenario
but here's the thing i was like i've
told i've told john a bunch of times
even though he's controlling it but
there was never an effort to get away so
like in one of the rounds
uh was it round three when you had the
back a lot so you were on his back and
you just had it but there was no
he wasn't trying to escape he was just
cool with hanging out with his forehead
against the fence which
which isn't good yeah which isn't good
yeah so yeah this this fight way out
punt
punted his coverage you'll by far yeah
bobby bobby bobby stephen
looks like bobby was landing a lot yeah
yeah i saw him laying on a bigger shirt
yeah i think i think bob i think bobby
probably won the third but i think he
might have lost one and two second was
close it really comes out of that he
lost the first for sure
close fight though but i honestly big
john i was talking about this on our
show i was like hey
like this is not a good fight for bobby
green not a good fight i mean i can't
believe you took it yeah
he's a stud man that's the theme about
the ufc man
you know there's there's these guys and
i can't believe we take that fight but
it's the ufc
dude yeah that's why it's impossible
like ufc so tough to bet on there's no
bartering though like
this decade you want this fight yeah
yeah you say yes or no that's it
that's right you see sugar shawn he on
his podcast uh and i love sugar shawn
he's talking about how
they want him to fight new york he's
like i don't fight new york dude like
taxes and yeah and he i guess his coach
can't go because his coach
has 80 uh some jutsu competition says i
don't have my head coach
he said i'll just fight like the next
month or the the whenever
i start in in vegas so i don't pay all
the taxes man yeah i guess uh sean
shelby is like all right
well have fun hanging out with takashi
six nine like come on
no no same [ __ ] happen to me with with
joe silva so i i've beaten ideas right
after i've beaten ideas
they call me a little while later and
they want me to fight they say okay
you're gonna fight for
pettis and i'm like all right cool fight
pettis for the title so then perez gets
injured so what do they do they call me
to fight
uh this tough [ __ ] dagger standing
russian guy yeah i can't remember i was
like i was like he wasn't even in the
top 15. i'm like yeah no i'm good man
yeah i'm also i'm good he's like well
perez is out so
something joe goes well fine [ __ ] you
can just sit out for six months
and so and then i told bob i said i said
look i made plenty of money i said you
can just tell them i'm okay with waiting
yeah i said give me a top five guy
i said i'll take it give me rda rda was
already matched up
i said give me somebody else give me
anybody in the top five a week later he
calls me with benson i'm like all right
cool i'll take it
i told you i said i'll take a fight if
you give me somebody in the top five
like i just i'm getting stuck i'm not
getting forced into fighting a guy who's
you know not in the top 15 or was like
he was right i didn't want to say he was
ranked like number
13 or 14 or something and for you tj's
is it guarantee right
guaranteed title shot i mean yeah 100
yeah i mean i just beat the number one
contender
you know [ __ ] coming off a two and a
half year layoff you got any uh
any thoughts on al jermaine versus i
think he's me on for sure
you know there's a lot going on in that
fight to first the he
yawn [ __ ] him up in the first fight oh
dude made him just quit and
bow out 100 illegal knee right so that's
the way that goes
but yawn dominated the fight um sterling
just got
neck surgery which i don't even know how
he's going to come back from that
anyways
it's a it's a tough task for al james
yeah so i think it's going to be beyond
the beginning of next year
yeah i agree so i agree it'll be a
little fight
yeah man i'm pumped on i think it's a
really good fight for me i'm excited for
it
um style matches up perfectly for me
that is a
fight but yawn
on the scene like right around the time
you were leaving for a little bit and
then yeah he wasn't even in the ufc when
i left yeah
well after he was in the ufc he wasn't
even there okay he moved up fast yeah
yeah he moved up fast i mean he had some
good fights yesterday
but i've never been like i was never
blown away by him like i
i would always like kind of pick against
him like all right yeah he's cool yeah
and then when i watch the aldo fight the
uh the aldo finals
dude this guy can this guy can box yeah
and then jamaican
was next like i thought al james would
be a bad matchup
no not in his wrestling but yeah dude
peter young
threw him around yeah he's got good
technique man he's like his basics are
good he's meat and potatoes yeah exactly
comes forward meat and potatoes
yeah boxing good defense he's on point
but that's i like what i know what i'm
getting
you know what i mean like going against
the guy that actually has like shitty
technique but makes it work for his
style
is harder to deal with than a guy that
throws what he's supposed to throw i
would say corey is tough to game plan
for
100 man corey with the knees yeah yeah
you know the darts
yeah the lane really long like just
explode one shot yeah
to be honest that was the title fight
that was like
you know corey's an animal bro he's
really good i've been saying it for a
really long time i knew that fight
going into it was going to be tough but
i knew how to beat him you know and i
could have beat him a lot
sound even more soundly if i would have
liked both my legs yeah
fair point you know yeah i have no
i talked legs big john a lot about cuts
and so
the cuts that go this way like
horizontally across your face they
normally don't stop
but your cut was going up and down and
so when i was talking with him we were
he's like he's like i'm surprised
because that's just sort of getting into
your
in your eyelid almost yeah so what he
says is like what happens if the cut
goes this way
the doctor will almost always stop it
based on the fact that his and get into
your tear duct and you'll have problems
with
your life sure yeah and so he just so
i'm surprised to be honest after i saw
especially at the end it was almost near
your eyelid
dude look i was like right here yeah
so it comes down and then it goes across
too yeah
you got that john wayne [ __ ] right there
yeah you look like a [ __ ] hockey
goalie i gotta i got from the
big 60s and [ __ ] i gotta give a big
shout out to tate
tate was the cut man in the corner um i
didn't know how bad it was i knew that i
was bleeding i couldn't [ __ ] see how
to keep wiping my eye because it's like
oil in your eye right like people don't
understand like blood's like very oily
like sweat right yeah i'd like to keep
wiping it i'd hold my hand up there like
i just like because i couldn't see
yeah you're really holding it like right
there well because i got hit with a left
hook and i think that was in the second
round too that put me to my butt
it wasn't the fact that it rocked me to
where i couldn't be on my feet but it
like hit me
and i couldn't put my left foot down
because i didn't see it coming it was
like kind of like caught me off guard
you know
and so after that i was like all right
[ __ ] it my hands just stay in here you
know
i think for corey too one of the reasons
like you know i'm closer with you but
came up with you know cory came to the
gym when he was 16 in our gym
corey's gonna be champ it's just not his
time now
like it's your time now like for corey
like he has time to
it's okay that he lost this one like
he'll he'll get there
no brandon it's never okay when you lose
bro that's sorry man
if he's fighting that but that but
that's how i
made it okay for him like yeah if he's
fighting tj it's okay he lost this one
yeah he's young
dude you know was he 28 yeah that's not
that young
is he 26 20 that's the prime man 20 20
26 27 to 33 is
kind of your prime 32-33 and you guys
were better my friend that's right
bro i mean he still got he got what
seven more years
yeah he's twenty nine
gotcha so my my ufc career has only been
10 years you know
yeah that's a long [ __ ] you know
every day right you like
yeah yeah let's watch all the interviews
every once in a while so how good of
friends were you
yeah so okay let's get back into this
training talk okay while we're waiting
for this uh show to start talk to him on
the train you train with him how many
times
and how did it really look like look be
honest did it go well for you what's up
my man hey
hey it's got a lot better looking in
here
good man
good i see i'm josh my brother
what's up big dog training was good man
brendan you go to a place where you're
gonna get pushed
yeah and i've had i've talked about this
in interviews i've always talked about
like i pumped him up about like days i'd
come home from
i come home from the gym and be pissed
because i got my ass whipped inspired
yeah
you know cory's one of those guys that
would do it you know i mean there'd be
guys even less
we got watched him that i get beat by
because when i'm in [ __ ] fight camp
you should beat me if i'm grinding
it looks like there should be me i know
i should be so worn out for sparring i'm
gonna get tired during sparring you're
gonna be fresh you know yeah that was
something that chael said i saw in a
video that like never clicked for me but
it's like this idea of like
i'm in fight camp cutting weight going
extra hard like and i'm supposed to beat
everyone's ass i'm doing
fresh i'm doing eight rounds right and
you're i'm wearing a fresh guy in every
round so you're taking a round off and
you're coming in and sparring me
yeah and i'm exhausted just from having
an eight-week fight camp
you know i just train my ass off the day
before so i'm gonna [ __ ] lose this i
got the target
you're trying for me like i'm trying to
get out and if you're making healthy and
if you're not losing rounds you're in
the wrong [ __ ] spot
those are the wrong those are the the
worst type of
like partners too like i saw when i
trained for nate i had a guy who came in
from hawaii his name was rambo we called
him rambo so he came in and
he would come in the last round say in
the fourth round or whatever you come in
the last round he's like
start talking [ __ ] to me come on yeah
his name's ryan come on yeah his name's
rambo it's like but with the
hawaiian accent it's like oh you
speaking pigeons yeah come on [ __ ] bro
come on it's like you like cracks i was
like [ __ ] so we just started like yeah
you just get to my
my nerves right when you have fighters
you know they're not on your level
yeah and they come in when you're not
fresh yeah you've already done two in
the morning you know you've done one
workout at five i've done another one
and you're sparring your fourth round
he's just coming in fresh like you piece
of [ __ ]
you should probably introduce our guests
that just sat down
the man the myth the legend mr brian
ortega
thanks coming brother uh yeah you got a
uh
you got a big fight coming up too man
yeah pretty big one title fight
okanowski uh september 25th
25th yeah it's a little bit of time is
that uh vegas they say vegas yeah
yeah all right that's a stock card man
oh yeah they got that card
the girl was fighting before that and
they got um
nick and robbie lawler yeah yeah that's
a great song
that's gonna do well pay-per-view yeah
yeah that's
that's more my era we're going
yeah i just finished training well
espn's been on my ass all day so i
showed up late oh really
yeah they've been they went to tiki's
place yesterday and then they were
at the track workout today then
from the track i want to go pick her up
from the airport and then uh
and then they wanted to film some more
and i'm like [ __ ] it's a lot yeah
and then now then we drive over here and
and you're coming from the ultimate
fighter like shooting
fighter which is that i don't think
people realize that especially for the
coach it's
it's a beast man yeah yeah like golden
fighters a beast to shoot man
yeah i didn't realize how much work it
was going to be yeah you know
what i told you you're like you're
filming non-stop and you're talking
non-stop
yeah i was like [ __ ] what does it feel
like training camp what do you think you
have on your chat bro it's not gonna get
easier
i didn't know what it would be like i
talked i talked to tj for a little bit
like hey dude like
shoot me you know like what's up but
he's right your coach lied to him
but he's
he was like bro like it's dope that you
like you'll see you're gonna make like
friendships in connection with these
guys
yeah and there's just gonna be a trip
and that's all i took from the
conversation he said yeah you guys
we didn't really talk like you're gonna
do this yeah you're shooting 40 hours a
day because he was he was uh
i was being one of those last guys in
the round for him
yeah um while he was in camp and i just
remember like hey dude i got
the call for the show how is it yeah and
he was getting ready for the first
yeah the first camp yeah the the first
camp you had with uh the guy you just
fought
yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah
he's one of the guys that was pushing me
and like those how did you guys train
together
kicked a little bit yeah like i'll let
him tee off
as long as i push him yeah but not be a
dick where you're like
i can go and do more because i know
you're tired
no no it's just like bro come on come on
like yeah it's all about the people i
watch the ultimate fighter i feel
and i feel like with you and volkanowski
like knowing you i know you
like he would be like playful and then
you took everything pretty personal you
know
bro this i tripped out i'll tell you why
i tripped out was because
he was shaking my hand and they said
like hey let's stir the part up mate
whatever whatever you know yeah like for
yeah for the show and i was like no like
like what sterling i'm real
yeah this is me [ __ ] like what do you
mean like stir the bottle like yeah he
doesn't know you very well i don't give
a [ __ ] like about
like i'm just here to coach this guy i
don't give a [ __ ] about trying to start
some [ __ ] with you no yeah
and then like he was all friendly then
the cameras come on and then he starts
talking
[ __ ] and i just can't help but start
laughing but i look like a dick you know
like
right everything he's saying i'm just
like because you know it's not real
you know what i'm laughing at it because
it's like this is not real and then i'm
like
but then like your insults are shitty
too
yeah yeah it was cringy yeah i was like
all you can say is i was late
it was tough and then like sometimes you
would say a little more things and then
i would get like
yeah then i would get heated yellow all
right [ __ ] like now you're using
this
thing to to secretly talk some [ __ ] you
could have really
legitly like one-on-one we're behind the
stage soccer show yep
are you glad you did it though did the
show yeah yeah
hell yeah it was it was a dope
experience yeah um
yeah i think it was just different
because
typically the people who do it hate each
other yeah there's usually some people
like
i didn't hate this guy there's no reason
yeah and even even then it was like
but like that's not your job right like
no you guys don't have to come up with
the animosity and like the
and like the sizzle for the show like
the ufc paired you guys together it's
like you know what you're getting
volkanovsky's good dude you're a good
dude it's like but they but they were
trying because i could tell like you had
20 cameras
and they were just you said they would
just let you stare at him like we would
stare at each other for like 20 minutes
and no one would say a word it's so
awkward
so then you're like what [ __ ]
like finally
every time he like he would break first
and then say he's one of your old
trained partners yeah
i'm actually never trying to he came to
alpha mill uh when i was gone
got it yeah yeah i actually think uh
song long dong wins dude you think he
wins i do
casey is the kid who is the kid who got
in trouble he's the one that got in
trouble on uh
sugar show yeah turn him out giving
heroin to kids or something like that
no no no no no what no no no
jesus
casey got in trouble because he made fun
of uh negan damn
megan anderson oh yeah yeah but that was
on that episode
it was on that episode talking about
giving kids heroin just that they didn't
care
ufc was like hey yeah whatever man [ __ ]
that you can't make fun of me
yeah yeah did they though he was still
on the card right because then he fought
uh cruz
yeah he fought dom yeah and he lost he
had a close fight split decision
was this with decision yeah i thought
dom won though i'm on it
it's close but i thought i got more i
don't want to so one of the comments
here i just wanted to check him
was ask ortega what he thinks about
brendan's
black belt promotion oh yeah
yeah yeah we gotta roll find out
i used to have to roll this dude all the
time yeah i was like what was like 20
years old and [ __ ] we're just rolling
yeah it was fun though and i knew i
would never take him down but i was
still shooting anyways and he [ __ ]
just sprawled me back
he's trying to [ __ ] and he would just
laugh and i'm gonna [ __ ] like i'm gonna
get a take down and i would go again and
you're just like blam myself
how much do you walk around with
tenacious 165. oh
that's so he's like 170 the heaviest
yeah like
at that point i was like 165 the
heaviest yeah but then he would go from
me
to the other dudes and me and henry just
sit back and watch him just [ __ ]
triangle
after triangle triangle yeah i was still
i was still trying though
yeah yeah i love seeing henry on the
ultimate fighter too man
it was yeah people don't realize how
good about how good of a coach you dude
even just like the couple practices that
came to your guys's and stuff and just
like watching the way he was coaching
you and the
positions he sees and the way he breaks
things down like
he's a very good coach he sees [ __ ]
that's like yeah
he sees he's really good he's got just
those quick little like darts chokes you
showing off the wall and stuff like yeah
you're gonna stick with me forever
that's so scary yeah he's an umbrella
he's good yeah so good
the good thing i like he's always
cooking something new yeah yeah it's not
like a a coach who
has
dive into foot locks for like he
literally will devote
three four years of his life to foot
locks yeah especially and then he'll go
i have this master from
escapes to sweeps like he masters it in
a bunch of different things and goes
okay now i'm going to shoot
to arm locks yeah now i'm going to shoot
into taking the back
and now i'm going to shoot into it seems
like an aspect of mma that just
rewards creativity like eddie bravo and
then with him
it's like i'm always next to him so even
if i don't want to learn and i'm going
to have to learn it anyways yeah
because sometimes he's like he was in
the footlocker and i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then he broke my foot and i'm like
well [ __ ] it
yeah yeah this [ __ ] works
do you look for foot locks and leg locks
when you're not really
no not really especially with fights i
don't think uh
unless you're a master at a foot lock
yeah even i look at it i don't look at
ryan hall
yeah i don't think you should be going
for foot locks in an mma right dicey
i feel like footlocks should be used as
a position to put
fear into them and use it as a sweep as
a result yeah
versus trying to get stuck there and
finishing while you get punched
right you know because if you're one you
mentioned if you dive in there you're
trying to figure it out
yeah yeah that's with foot locks with
leg locks and foot locks
it's one of those you attack as fast as
you can if you don't get it you use it
to get back on top
yeah if once you don't get it get out
get it i'll put a fear in you and then
once you run i use that as a sweep and
now get on top
yeah but it's more a sweep than it is
yeah an actual submission we're not
trying to hang out there what was the
guy that uh frank mir did that against
uh
[ __ ] talk about leglock yeah frank muir
did it against somebody a long while
brock lesnar no somebody else
thing for the fight so he did the fight
and it was able to finish and he was
frank he finished frank
because hammer fisted him because frank
kept trying to hit the leg up to it you
squished him in and just [ __ ] hammer
fisted him knocked him out
yeah yeah this is water if you want a
water yes she's just watercolor i know
it looks it looks like a tall boy but
it's water yeah
that was beard liquid yeah chappelle's
got one of these every morning when we
when he picks me up
yeah and i love him yeah brian looked at
it like uh what are you giving me
probably
it's like i'm a camera i was like roman
canvas
seven after this weekend i think yeah
yeah still a long camp
yeah you got a long camp i'm already
[ __ ] i feel great already
you look great that last night like uh
you can't you're you
knew camp too from previous yeah from
everything yeah it was
hannah's only one stayed yeah if he
would have got rid of henry we
had been we would have been questioning
your choices yeah no
i would have lost but we wouldn't have
fought
no you big [ __ ] i can run faster
how's that jeep doing man it's dope
yeah it's dope do you get hooked up
because uh
you know i get my car hooked up like
tuned and stuff like that do they take
care of you or
everything it has a supercharged like
yeah it's insane
have you seen his have you seen this
jeep oh it's not insane
bringing us [ __ ] up it's the most insane
jeep you've ever
put a supercharger on it from these guys
at craftworks [ __ ]
they just saw my jeep and they just
souped it all the way up did they see it
like came in it's even better than that
that's when it was on street wheels not
having legit on like uh is on your
instagram right now yeah like monster
trucker ones yeah
i have like real like real beat locks
like 40 inch tires like
you're taking a wheel in yet [ __ ] yeah
dude that thing is insane
but with those giant tires it can't be
too fast right
bro it has a supercharger tires are
[ __ ]
loud like as long as you have the axles
down right that way you don't have like
it's made out of gears too you just
gotta lower the gears on it yeah yeah
the guy
i don't think i have on my social you
know what maybe down back in the down a
little bit like burned down
l.a after the final october i have like
a photo of that with like the impala
that
that i have and i did like a little cool
la and they just shoot oh there's that
one
yeah that's when they supercharged it
that thing looks
nuts yeah actually does donuts
like legit burnouts and they just say
hey leave it with us and we'll
we'll hook it up yeah my homie uh so
check this there you go
geez that thing's nuts so
my homie the guy who who did the jeep he
used to work out of a garage and was
like a jeep
nerd like just dove in like
jeeps yeah yeah and i was like i saw
what he did to my car initially
initially and i was like
cool i got like 10 15 friends that are
that's on my jeep and they got jealous
so they're right the same [ __ ] yeah yeah
can you do it and he's like oh [ __ ]
that's a lot of work okay
he's like [ __ ] you don't make money or
not yeah yeah right
and uh it went from like a hobby to his
and then now he has a shop
oh damn it legit business they're like
bro we're in a [ __ ] pandemic you want
to make money or not yeah
like come on does he have one of those
bumper stickers says it's a jeep thing
you wouldn't understand
no yeah you ever seen those it's like
yeah i've gone to some little courses
they have they'll set they'll go like
like a bull arena and they'll set like
man-made courses
that's designed to flip you and like get
you stuck and everything and oh
nice they dropped you in there and like
and i threw my thing in there and i
actually passed the test oh
no i'm like but i was a shitty driver
the guys were like oh yeah i just want
to go fast man
you're a porsche guy oh yeah dad's out
there that monster's out there
did you drive the jeep yeah i took my
dad's jeep over here all right
it's uh yeah type move because uh
someone's gonna keep my jeep right now
someone someone someone has my jeep for
camp right now uh not a bad gig driving
thing around
uh this is the first five main car we
have a clicker up anyways though right
so people know where we're at yeah
you got this guy tj yeah i think song
dong is going to win
i think he's uh underdog though i know i
think he's a tank bro he's a hard hitter
and like i know like he [ __ ] uh yeah
cheetos beat him they like so dong
seong won but uh i think cheeto should
have won the fight
um but this casey kinney guy like he did
a good job against cruz but i don't
think he's got enough like power
to we'll see i just don't think he's got
enough pop in his shots
the thing what song you know like is
that his name i'm saying
song you know something we don't know
what's going on possibly
he leaves himself open to be hit quite a
bit he has that very kind of straight up
and down
stand up he's got power though any
predictions for a main event
i have i have a weird feel as the night
gets closer i feel like derrick lewis is
going to win yep i
i feel the same way wait i've been pre
i've been on serial guns
nuts for the past months because
footwork's so good
he shouldn't be the favorite he's not
athletic he doesn't get hit he never
gets hit
i'm dude he's very
they had like four swipes and they were
all like mini videos of them sparring
and they're going pretty hard oh [ __ ]
this guy's good i know yeah he's [ __ ]
good
i was like he's so athletic bro he's
gonna be so aware of derek
derrick
oh [ __ ] yeah he's nasty he's just so
athletic and like
his technique's insane for a heavyweight
the problem with him is if he if he does
win you're gonna get five round boring
decisions yeah like he's not a
really exciting fighter he doesn't knock
anybody out he's just technical he's
super technical doesn't get hit
just wins rounds well especially if
you're playing ufc he's like dear god
don't win
if you're fighting a guy that's got
power in your hands you have to fight
that way right like you got to fight to
an extent of being smart keep your
distance move
i think he fought rosenstein hits i mean
obviously it's probably francis derrick
lewis 1a1b
then rose street's probably second in
that division as far as hitting hard
roadstreak didn't [ __ ] touch a man
but it wasn't a fun fight but you gotta
look at derrick uh
derrick lewis and ghana remember when
they fought the worst fight the worst
fighter straight times
but i think if they if they do fight
again it would be different
yeah they'll feel the pressure and
someone's just like alright [ __ ] it
let's just get in the face do you see
that meme where it was like
gone like superior boxing kickboxing
grappling
conditioning everything that being said
derek lewis round three tql
yeah that's where i'm at that's right
all week i was giving god all this stuff
and then
this morning i woke up like oh derek
lewis gonna knock him out in his
hometown
yeah and apparently like he he has been
training
i saw some of his coaches talking
derrick like they're like he's i've
never seen him he's taking a serious
yeah
i mean dude if you're changing [ __ ] up
like i don't know maybe no
because he's obviously training harder
because there's that much more pressure
on him
he's not just training just because
right it's like he's that much more
nervous about getting this title
no i might say
when did he come on below the belt years
ago remember when i was doing the tv
show downtown
yeah during the tv show was that four
years ago maybe three four
three four years ago he was there and it
was uh
either after i forget what it was but he
was just basically like yeah i'm done
man
that's he said i'm sick of my kids
making fun of me when i lose he was like
there's like all these kids yeah i'm
thinking they're making fun when i lose
i'm just sick of this [ __ ]
i was like dad you can't be done dog and
then the ufc must have threw him [ __ ]
stacks
because then he signed a six-fight deal
like that next monday so
yeah he's taking seriously he got really
frustrated after he lost to dc he just
was like conditioning cardi because that
was for the title that's right
that was for the heavyweights yeah that
was for the heavyweight title so
that's when he started actually getting
in better shape his conditions are
getting better his last two feet lost a
lot of weight
not just losing the weight but his last
two fights in the third round he's the
one pushing forward
yeah and if he gets on top of you i
would i can't imagine more handsome
yeah too really really he is he is very
very very noticeable yeah you see that
video of him and his kid on the
four-wheeler no no on his uh instagram
there's like him and his kid on the four
wheelers he played on fire in the kid
remember
yeah and actually all that's right and
his and his kid grabbed the throttle
yeah it was in gear he saved them
[ __ ] ran right into the house
yeah jeff ernest
i feel like he has pressure now for his
post-fighting ideas and they're not as
good
because before it was so organic it was
him yeah and then now i feel
he feels the pressure yeah like every
every time he's like i take a [ __ ] man
like you use that last time
right yeah yeah the balls was hot was
this all-time like unexpected great
balls is hot greatest one ever
i like that i gotta go doodoo yeah yeah
he's so funny man
yeah if he wins he sets the so set the
record for most knockouts ever and
you'll see history
so you have to dude if he wins it's
going to be so good for the ufc yeah
because you do him for francis it'll get
francis out of you know whatever he's
dealing with
and they're talking about john john
verstipe
apparently stephen accepted the fight
there's waiting on john mm-hmm
johnny gonna accept it so i think he
should get his beak wet
had heavyweight fight you know arguably
the greatest heavyweight at all time in
the fc he won't fight unless he gets
paid though
yeah and they don't want to give him the
money yeah
hopefully they do he's looking thick
but like in a good way in a good way
yeah
he's doing all that speed training and
[ __ ] too though he looks [ __ ] good
here's my thing too about john i used to
train with a man and he
he wouldn't go with like middleweights
and light heavyweights it'd be like
me alice drovering travis brown like
those were his rounds
big guys andre arlovski yeah it was all
heavyweights yeah
[ __ ] up everybody that was back then
yeah when he's coming late
like that's interesting it's not gonna
be a problem for him oh there you are
brian
well how many i've got was this long
season ever i've been watching i've been
trying to keep up with it yeah
is it 19 episodes
yeah i put it this way
and i'm not like i don't even [ __ ]
watch
the whole show why would you you went
through it
i watched two what do we watch three
episodes three episodes together and
i haven't watched [ __ ] since yeah yeah
like i know everything that happened
i talked to the guys yeah you know
what's going on uh
yeah and then a lot of things that
happened like i'm like [ __ ] like
the way they got to make a reality show
like a lot of gold
is lit at least in my opinion like gold
things that happened
fit the narrative like you know what we
did that okay so we did the uh
i think they just i saw because you see
like the weekly updates on
something on social media at least i
kind of have an idea where they are
they did a challenge where they changed
the tires for a car
so like nascar style like this yeah
like on a like a baja like oh 1000 yeah
yeah
and uh sure enough like we like we lost
that challenge
but me and tiki took off in my car in
the jeep and then
the guy took off too and like we took
off across the street from that lot
and we started just [ __ ] made like
we're doing donuts together like that's
cool
and like some crazy [ __ ] was like we
unleash hell on that dirt
that dirt like yeah so we're like the
guy working for the ufc team called like
the cops or whatever
like what the hell security was cause
you know why ufc can hear that right
yeah yeah because it [ __ ] looks
recognized because
like you're playing as you but it was
like but it happened
you know the plan is for you to beat
volkowski and they can't have you like
this
crazy [ __ ] daredevil i don't know bro
it's something
yeah that's true it does but it doesn't
fit brian you know it's like brian's a
stand-up you know what i'm saying
but i loved the fun [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah it is weird with ultimate product
because you remember there there's
producers so it's basically real world
cage fighting and they still gotta put a
whole new dude there's like if you would
have got hurt
it would have been our ass and then i
was like
but did you die like yeah yeah did you
die
then donald 5000 is like yeah i did yeah
right yeah
in the ambulance it's actually crazy how
much they can switch up
when they film it that you i think it's
going to go exactly how it was filmed
they'll switch the order of fights
they'll [ __ ] they'll switch
their interviews not sure exactly those
they'll show weird stuff like
on my season where i knew like i thought
it was just all right this is a
competition
that's what it is yeah and then rashad
and i were training partners but rashad
was my coach
so the when they were making the fights
i went after a shot i was like hey i
sparred with kimbo i will
and i wasn't friends with kim about time
i was like i will [ __ ] destroy that
dude
give me him i'll submit in 30 seconds
rashad's like bet that's the fight i'm
like hell yeah fighting kimbo
it's getting so many views i was like
couldn't sleep the night before
next morning they go to do the
announcements
and uh dana's like it's roy nelson
versus uh kimbo
i get in the back i'm like what's up
what the [ __ ] he's like call from the
from the top dude
that wasn't the fight they wanted to get
a red phone call yeah i was like what
he's like all right that's when i
realized i'm like oh
i'm on this isn't i'm on a reality show
that's what's going on here yeah yeah
they did not want kimbo to succeed yeah
damn
so he gave him the worst possible
matchup yeah a black belt who has
former world champion with 30 fights
like and kimbo has
no ground game you know what i'm saying
so it's just like worst case scenario
for him
shitty deal for him but then there was
also some guys who were like yeah man
the way they edit i look like an ass i'm
like oh dude you know you're an [ __ ]
yeah you didn't know that you didn't oh
you didn't know that no no that's how
you
that's how you talk but like you know
i was like you're the guy
saying that yeah dude there's you know
like [ __ ]
yeah it's like oh no you're just an
[ __ ] until you see the show it's like
guys say that all the time whoa i just
gave up and i just know i'm an [ __ ]
but you might be in that environment
like that's not a real environment dude
you're there against
your will world champion yeah you're
there you know you gotta do a job like
that's not
the real brian ortega like you're there
the guy you're gonna fight soon is that
you know what i'm saying it's like
it's heightened [ __ ] it's tough yeah
it's weird maybe an [ __ ] yeah
maybe i [ __ ] i don't know now i don't
think henry let you become an [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
yeah henry was trying to stop me like
from certain ideas that i had yeah
but he was like don't do that such as
for example
just just a situation that i was like
all right
this guy actually what else i bro i
don't give a [ __ ] i go i'm gonna swing
on someone probably like
but yeah because yeah because i don't
want to like
yeah but it's like like even even for
you when you
slapped uh korean zombies manager who's
uh
[Laughter]
chin's friends with him and chin was
like can you believe ryan did that
i'll go [ __ ] yeah like right stop
talking
is he not his manager he just deals with
his social media you don't have to talk
about it
yeah it was knowing you like that was
out of character
if you had any idea of what my week was
like that week
you would understand like stress just
sit like
i don't know if tikki's getting mad if i
speak right now
who's getting it but that provides some
context that we didn't know
like you know hey put it this way i got
in a fight
i got in a fight on a friday some
crazy [ __ ] happened on a thursday so
you're just i was on a bomb on that one
and then you saw him yeah and i wasn't
getting in trouble like to the point
where like it's
like some [ __ ] happened uh
in vegas and [ __ ] like right the
friday before that fight
got in got in a fight uh
[ __ ] cops had had us like belly down
and [ __ ] and the guy looks at me like
brian like what the [ __ ]
say [ __ ] do you know what are you doing
bro
[ __ ] jump bro like yeah yeah they
don't like that oh yeah i think it's
like my homies getting jumped so i'm
gonna
help them out i just i can't think i
just gotta act right
i'm like oh my career like i see you
again
i see four guys on you that have
something yeah we are uh
trained not to think yeah i mean like
you think you lose
but then when you unleash that [ __ ]
inside of you and you then you see the
aftermath you're like
cops don't see [ __ ] happened for guys
it shows that they're all [ __ ] asleep
someone's [ __ ] hitting
guys just so good triangle
but the cops saw me let me go which was
good nice
and then uh
yeah i was already see not all cops guys
not all cops
and uh so yeah and then i [ __ ]
told the homeboy if i saw him i'd slap
him
yeah because he was controlling his
social media right he was
at the end like when i talked to korean
zombies said he wasn't whatever
i think it was just a misunderstanding
misunderstanding i don't know i like
that i like yeah i like those guys
but i just felt like bro like in my
opinion was like just stay out of it
like the fight's already happening
we're not getting pay-per-view buyers
like i went to korea i showed nothing
but love over there i was
respectful even when he told me like hey
dude it was my team yep
and i said [ __ ] like it is like [ __ ] it
bro like just yeah we don't have to be
[ __ ] every fight
to each other to promote it like i think
we're two good fighters
it's not gonna be it's not your nature
it's not natural for you so when this
little guy like when this guy starts
kind of acting up on social media and
like
kind of like in my the way i took it was
like he's kind of puffing his chest i'm
like hold up [ __ ] like you're
not a regular guy
he's a rapper where where uh
like if someone talks [ __ ] okay but it's
like bro we're
we're gonna run into each other yeah i'm
gonna see you yeah
it's not like something inside yeah and
it's like i'm and i'm nice with everyone
yeah i don't have issues with anyone
rather than even volcanos whatever like
i don't have issues with anyone
yeah so i was like bro just stop that
[ __ ] and he still kind of kept fighting
all right [ __ ] like
yeah wait till i see you yeah and then i
i didn't even know he was there until
like i looked back and i was like
[ __ ] he's there i swear that's what ran
through my head i was like
[ __ ] like i'm been already in the world
of [ __ ] from this week
we're like well i guess i get a slap and
that's what i told myself [ __ ] dude
and i walked up like i jumped over the
chair and i was just like
look i don't want to do this and i still
didn't realize i still didn't even i
wasn't even sure if it was him or not
yeah and i said hey [ __ ] what's
your [ __ ] name korean people
no no
you have to ask his name i was just like
hey [ __ ] what's your name
yeah if you would be like hey bro
relax i want to [ __ ] did [ __ ] yeah
but what i want to do but he was just
like
like he was like oh like jay park like
the way he said i go oh yeah
[ __ ] like all right
and then it was like [ __ ] all right that
just happened
but if you're gonna do it's probably the
best place to do it yeah the ufc was
like okay let's get them out
oh no not the best place bro oh really
[ __ ] you know what happened did they
beat you up in the back
i got taken to the back and then another
liquid death
i thought it was like whatever something
happens it is what it is yeah well
they're all
still yours well now they're like hey
dude you have to like you have to sit
here and wait if they're gonna press
charges you're not in this and then i
was like
and then all of a sudden i'm like [ __ ]
yeah like all right now i'm stuck here
now if the cops come and they have me
they're all silly and then they're like
uh who press charges though too
you know what i'm saying put it this way
they said no one's present charges get
the [ __ ] out of here i'll go to my homie
suite
security starts coming i'm like you're
like where you guys doing
this [ __ ] don't look right yeah i
thought we were good so i was like hey
bro
could be a solid like what's the [ __ ]
going on yeah they're like cops are on
their way to the rescue
uh he's pressing charges now ah that's
kind of did he really do that that's a
[ __ ]
no no no okay at that time at the time
he thought about it because i was just
like [ __ ] i go
no that's not cool oh come on bro i
didn't [ __ ] you slap by the way you
didn't do it joe shilling no
and uh what grown man president charges
though come on
that's what i was doing press charges
well i had a [ __ ] fleet of t-mobile
arena like hiding out from the cops and
[ __ ]
crazy and the [ __ ] security like high
spri i had to put the security like yo
do me
like solid get the [ __ ] out the door
like move out the way homie you never
saw me like they were cool brian brown
i was like how many [ __ ] years have i
known you come on i was like just do me
that favorite thank you for the main
event here in two
weeks i was like they come over here you
didn't see me that's it like i want to
take a shower
or whatever and [ __ ] all worked out
man
and took off and then the bad the reason
why that's bad is because he could have
sued me
and the ufc because i threatened him
already
and knowing like they were supposed to
take care of him well because it was
pre-meditated like you
yeah it was like yeah so ufc security
whatever could have got sued
uh i could have got i was gonna get sued
um i mean who sues these days
and then uh everyone i i found myself in
a situation like [ __ ] went to a fight
and a fight broke out what the [ __ ]
happened
koreans are very litigious but about
wait what what's his name again
jay park or jay park jay park yeah and i
like jay park but it's but it's also
like that's like that's the game you're
playing right exactly if you talk [ __ ]
to brian ortega
and then you come to a ufc event that
brian's at and brian say he's going to
slap you
will keep that same energy when he see
him even though he's a good guy
but he was getting his homies out of the
window he was going he's getting his
homies he said there was a
misunderstanding too it wasn't even him
on the
texting that's there's just a
misunderstanding right but the whole
thing where if he's acting tough
it might be funny everything at the end
of the day was all just bad
communication yeah i have a question
though who said who sat you guys next to
each other no let me
this day is unclear bro let me tell you
something the second i get there i never
even saw homeboy yeah i put that up
on everything i love my kids everything
i go
i go in there and the second i get there
if you look up uh
korean zombies footage literally as i
walk by
his wife's already filming me uh his
wife's like this
and i'm like [ __ ] like one i won't ever
[ __ ] fight a guy
with his wife there out of respect why
for kids
i'll catch you later yeah wait in the
tally mafia
i mean i feel like that's respect
so and then i and i walk and i say hi to
i think it was a
dan i say hi to dan bilzerian he was
there i was partying with him like on a
thursday night
uh say what's up to a couple people and
then
um i look over and she's still filming
me i go okay now they're
in my opinion i go they're trying to
poke me like poke the bear yeah
but like why do that i go all right cool
and then [ __ ] it who's with you hannah's
not i have one guy
named julian with me one of my agents
and then i'm chilling and uh
i see i see him get up and leave and i'm
like
i'm looking i'm looking i'm like all
right like whatever
and i look over at this chair and i
start like playing these fake like these
thoughts in my head like
but if i was to run at him
scenarios yeah like i'm going through
scenarios in my head
and then jj was going to uh the girl
from china yeah
everyone starts standing up and i'm
sitting and i look over at his chair
still like
and then it's empty the chair is empty
but i'm still like my [ __ ] mind's in
like a different state
if he was there and then i look in the
throat behind him
and everyone's standing up except this
one guy
and he looked a little bit fidgety it's
like [ __ ] i'm gonna get slapped no and
then i went like that
in my head i go that's that [ __ ]
look
like i had a vibe i go that's him and i
go yo julian
do me a favor i have no service here
look up that guy jake uh
or jay parker please
what ago i have a i think that's him
i go can you please look him up he looks
him up i go to his uh his uh
social media did you see him start
zooming in on the tattoos he has
i go bro i can't tell but i think those
are the same tattoos it's a match
i go it's closer to 48. it's like it's
close enough if i go [ __ ] it
it's closer you got the same tattoos as
the dude
i gave him the phone and i just jumped
over and i [ __ ]
and that's why i asked i go hey what's
your name only like yeah what the [ __ ]
your name
yeah if you would have said something
outside he's like jake perk
i'm not trying to say that but [ __ ] it
like you know that's what it was and it
happened
but at least it's over with me it's over
with but and when we talked about the
show we kept saying like
there's no way it's looking sick what
were you saying that's roger clemens
oh well we talked about the show we kept
saying like that's not brian
yeah that's not right at all that's not
his character we just kept saying that
he's there but he's wrong the thing is
like maybe you say that it's not like i
said it on interviews
like yeah i've literally set out
interviews if you piss me off to the
point where i'm like man
[ __ ] you like it's for real but if it
got but if there's a reason for it
so that there's a reason for it at that
point you wouldn't just do it you just
not just randomly hit something yeah
people thought like i was trying to hype
to fight or
whatever i didn't think that or some
people were like why
brian stupid why would he do that
picking on the innocent part like
i got so much [ __ ] from it dude like it
was crazy
but then all that squash once you guys
fight well like where i come from at
least what we're taught to like
if you can't [ __ ] if there's beef
between people you shut the [ __ ] up
yes you don't get involved and if you
get if you get involved
there's repercussions you might like
some [ __ ] might happen yeah yeah
and uh although we are professionals and
everything like this we're also fighters
bro like yeah
especially and people forget people
forget what god is
yeah what's like you know what god is
fighting
and having jobs is fighting correct like
at least for me like i [ __ ] my entire
life
yep street well mm whatever it was like
we would always fight
yeah we didn't like each other the way
we settled it is like
we knuckle up and that's it did you see
the joe schilling thing the guy was like
talking [ __ ] to him talking [ __ ] to him
and then you know joe schilling does
what joe schilling does knock them out
and everyone wants to be up in arms
about like but also like that drunk guy
talking [ __ ] joe schilling's like
that's what happens dude yeah like if
you talk [ __ ] someone there's gonna be
some reaper did you forget we're not on
facebook right now [ __ ] that's
like really when it comes out
like people talk [ __ ] to me online and i
just always have to i'm like you know i
bet you like a thousand bucks you
wouldn't say that to my face
yeah but it just is the case obviously
with fighters even more so it's like
people are
it's like i'm a professional fighter and
you're gonna you're gonna talk [ __ ] to
me like you know me especially joe
schilling though it's like he's smoking
cigarettes he has his [ __ ] ears it's
like dude world-class
striker it's like what do you think is
going to happen people are out of touch
with reality
exactly well that guy got a dose of
reality i mean
no yeah it's just it's it's weird bro
i'm glad that this
is weird i had to wait a year and i just
i don't apologize actually that's the
only way he didn't press charges
he was like he was like dear jay you
know you know this shit's
fake right you know she's fake i'm not
apologizing but he was like
it took me three apologies because i was
[ __ ] stubborn yeah
yeah but here's a thing i literally was
but you're still a businessman at the
end of the day and i and
one thousand percent yes and i [ __ ] up
and i forget sometimes or
or like i said that week like i have
i'll show you after this like i'll show
you the [ __ ] bar fight i had i'll
show you like
the other [ __ ] like that's not going to
happen let's not do that anymore yeah
let's not do that no
the security the security sent me the
the footage
yeah no no the security sent me the
footage that's it
you make a ton of money to fight stop
fighting outside of the cage stop let me
just stop
let me tell you all right let me tell
you way back
i know i might sound like i have excuses
after excuses but listen
my hum my cousin right mm-hmm uh
he was drunk hey now this can get you in
trouble right tell me stories
all right i hope not i don't need you to
travel no that happened that happened
okay good i don't want to eat my cousin
long story short that's my [ __ ]
writer though your cousin yeah
sure he's like he he got out he did
eight years okay like that [ __ ]
got mad love for me yeah it's a long
time
um he hits me up 24 hours is a long time
by the way yeah
and that's my good channel
yeah yeah and uh so he's out he's
about you know like i'm taking care of
him watching over him and [ __ ]
uh he got he started drinking but he
wasn't drunk
he was just drinking but i know he's
driving and he's up the street from my
house i said hey bro i'm gonna go pick
you up
i'm gonna take you home like you don't
need to get dui and and and break
uh parole or anything on some stupid
[ __ ] yeah hashtag good guy yeah don't
get don't get a
gear bullet yeah for some stupid [ __ ]
yeah
and to me i go i'm two miles from where
you're at it's nothing to me just come
to my house and just
sleep over here i literally walk in
i shake his hand and then the drink
spills on someone's jeans
this at a bar yeah okay i say my bad bro
but the guy had
[ __ ] with him and then i go hey bro let
me like
let me buy you a drink he's like not
flat oh no
like bro let me buy you and your homies
a drink like like and he still wasn't
having it and he
he got up and then finally just can your
cousin fight
you do eight years you leave me no
choice you never know you're doing eight
years and glad you're here
you know i know he's drunk but yeah
eight years you either you know
no he could be a guy hold a pocket he's
a gladiator no no he's uh
no no you don't have to present
is actually one of my favorite lesbian
fighters in the ufc
top three at least top three
[Laughter]
she's a badass though i think angela
hill beats her though
this time around you think so yeah yeah
she's not she's underdogs she she
doesn't do well with
what she's like if she can't get you
yeah like if you know
yeah she's good yeah she's just the
decisions never go her way
i get to pee so hard i'm trying to be
like rogan where he doesn't peter in
shows but
i'm just not joe rogan but we're also
drinking whiskey during the show
so does he though dude he's having a
camel he can hold it for four hours
damn i know i try to be like him that's
why he makes the big bucks
you're right you know what i mean like
0.02 what he makes
you guys hold the fourth down i'm sorry
hey have you noticed though he [ __ ]
he doesn't talk about his contract at
all he doesn't talk about his deal at
all people try to hit him up on his show
about it
no i know i get what you're saying but
but it's kind of already been out there
i'm sure not the details been up there
but i think people try to get him hey
man i [ __ ] yeah but you don't hear a
great job when you're
that can get in the new car he's like
yeah okay you don't want to try it
at all but yeah he doesn't want to make
the show about him and that's how
successful he is yeah but it's all same
with like
you know nfl player or baseball player
signs a new deal or
like brian like once he beats
volkanowski let's say he signs a huge
deal
yeah you know i'm not gonna bring it up
on here dude six fights
[ __ ] hundred million what i mean like
yo [ __ ] guess what i just made
legit tries to change the conversation
to something else yeah so it's awesome
it's awkward for me yeah i know people
like that because you feel like it's
unreal but
it's also like it's kind of yeah i mean
it's just the world we live it's kind of
unfair like
it'd be great if like that number if
spotify just went like yeah we signed
rogan
you know everyone's like yeah damn i
wonder how much you made but it's like
yeah we signed rogan 100 mills
god damn why you gotta throw that out
there yeah yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying
yeah but you can't argue he's the most
influential person of our time right now
dude
yeah he's well by far yeah he's the male
oprah you know what i'm saying
remember when she would just be like hey
this book's good and the book would
[ __ ] sell jacob
that's how rogan is you go on there and
say anything about anything and it sells
out
yeah yeah yeah yeah she's got her she if
el can go extinct it's gonna be trying
to start her own network and didn't work
oprah
yeah yeah she's worth like damn near a
billion dollars how much is oprah worth
jen i think more than rogues yeah the
richest girl the richest female in the
royal
right now is the girl that did the harry
potter books wrong oh who is it now the
lady who divorced [ __ ]
oh bill gates jeff bezos if you want to
narrow it down to none
is it is it here it's her she's the
richest female in the world okay okay
like 53.
that makes yeah that makes sense because
what's her name is also uh steve jobs
narrow it down to people who earned
their own ex-wife she's worth
uh not more than she was basically she's
worth she's worth 50 million though jeff
bezos broke up with
his wife and then got this girl with a
crooked eye it's pretty cool i'm gonna
take this yeah
i love crooked eyes i love crooked eyes
is there any comments mark any good ones
good ones what's your idea
we didn't read comments on this page i
thought we interviewed this is a thing
now
you know let's see all right man i'm not
gonna lie i got a little crush on this
girl she's hot
she's she's so cute like she's just she
fights hard she comes out aggressive
here's a funny one surprised mark didn't
use his ass cheeks to pick the ice out
okay all right yes i like that one it's
cause he's got him
[Laughter]
normally i would
who wins now that you're here at the
table who wins
who wins female fighters let's go uh who
is it hillary
clinton
yeah okay put that aside though she
can't
i can't you can't do that that's that's
the friend right there
no i feel like i this is how i feel i
feel like the first fight was a good
fight yeah
i think that teaches got a lot better
but so is angela anne's got a lot better
she's a lot more confident in what she
throws out yeah she's and i think that
you'll be training it and you're like
okay
yeah her output though her output is a
lot more than when they when they fought
the first time
uh i seen her like with with the janet
from like the one
one champion okay and that one girl um
jackie
i don't want to miss from ufc or she
she's they're both from one oh from one
but they're just like these stand-up
girls or
uh is it uh one champion the female girl
there yeah
they they're talking about a place
called boxing works yeah yeah angela's
been training
her goal with her and she trained with
them i saw that she was there that's her
girl in the back right
just guy is that right no kel pennington
raquel pennington
yeah right she's from colorado too i
should know that somebody asked me who's
my favorite gay fighter in the ufc i
don't know
do you know any brandon fighters
he's like [ __ ] you man yeah i don't
think there's anything that's uh
come out just statistically though
brian's like volkanovsky
[Laughter]
yeah i'll never forget when i was
playing college football my uh
my coach goes i don't know why i said
this we're in the middle of cambodia
statistically
one in eight men is gay
there's 12 of us in here
quiet let me start pointing fingers
jerry's gay
the other day i was like you
[ __ ] i didn't know you guys
trained together man
yeah tikki's our managers we've been
training at tiki's gym
dude i've known tiki forever so because
you and i
linked up and then tiki text means hey
it's tiki man
he's i'm working with brian i'll take
care of everything i'm like dude i mean
i haven't talked to him forever he was
on my uh ultimate fighter
like 15 years ago dude wow me and tika
were close man that's where they had the
best prank
yeah yeah yeah yeah to use i love tj
i've had a lot of managers
and tiki's by far the best he's well
he's been around for seven thousand
years i mean
he's been around forever because he
worked with rampage forever right yeah
yeah
i just saw rampage yesterday yeah him in
chicago he's uh
his rampage and shavers he's stupid he's
actually looking better really because
he was like
he's like thank you fight the fate of
the fight
he's like 290. no he's actually looking
better he's been training with mckee
and those guys up there in the little
body shop being motivated yeah
he looks he looks they announced fedor's
fight yeah
tim johnson fight not a good fight for
tim no it's a great fight for tim
yeah i mean i i figured for fedor i
think tim i think tim knocks him out and
i give him 40. definitely yeah but i
figured fate or they'd like give him
like a josh barnett like another legend
nah i don't know he he wanted matt
mitchell and then matt had lost five in
a row because he wanted that fan they
cut up
yeah because matt had lost five or six i
thought they were like would jack give
him josh barnett
let john you know joshua yeah the issue
with joshua is you know if he's gonna
make it to the fight
you know he has problems with the
commissions you know i know you're in
russia we're in russia
i get it i watched so four guys beat up
one guy in russia
but as a promotion though you saw that
[ __ ] too i saw it
the
literally i watched three guys beat the
shot on one guy and it was a sanctioned
fight
it was fantastic three versus one dude
it was nuts
but i think it'd be like one big guy
like the mountain from game of thrones
so yeah
first three small guys is three small
guys versus one small guy
the first guy dives in just takes it
down and then the two guys just stomp
them out yeah i was like this is
fantastic they're building middle and i
want to donate to their building
dude we watched that hunt down below did
they beat that it was actually
it was actually in poland but there's a
ton of like russian like
team fights oh dude russia they do the
game of thrones ship where they have
gear and swords
mma fight you've seen that i can't get
enough of it
and the goal is to kill somebody yeah
and you tell me josh barnett can't get
sanctioned in russia
i think it's a promotion though you want
to stay away from things that might
attract more
garbage for you but josh barnett's a
legend yeah but i think he's been i
think he got us suspended again
i think that's kind of what the issue is
though i think there was some sort of
suspension all right something josh
going on what about those
jose dos santos what about uh i'll just
have a fight and haven't fought in
bellator so why have those guys fight
there
that's the biggest thing so why have
them fighting you guys you guys did
kimbo verse
this is before you got there but yeah it
was before no i actually just signed
with them oh really
you worked that fight yeah i actually
interviewed that was my very first
interview before you interviewed dada
when he died
[ __ ] kimbo oh he was the very first
like you know it's like but you died
donald's like yeah
he did that yeah i didn't die he died
dude he straight up died inside the
gun and then they resuscitated him and
then he came back to life yeah
because i guess he kept so much weight
before that fight because he was like
290 out of shape
265. and they were so out of
how about uh your boy uh well your old
friend chad men has uh signed with bare
knuckles yeah
i was surprised i mean i think it's good
for bare knuckle like there's something
there
do you have a better knuckled old friend
you watch it all right uh i don't
know you know what i'm saying [ __ ] let's
say [ __ ] like you've seen
men he's got a great contract man yeah
they do pay and i think
they pay like there's something yeah
they pay well there's something to bear
knuckle i think if they keep getting
guys like chad mendes stuff like that
they could be onto something yeah the
thing is looking but good
but all the but all the people they've
signed up his hand looks sick yeah
he looks good right i see i see a little
video like yeah
or the bag i thought for sure he's
coming back to ufc they must not no
when i saw reti like out of retirement i
thought it was ufc
and that's him but she could he could
come back and compete yeah he could but
it's like dude they're offering him some
good money
yeah you know yeah but you're fighting
bear knuckle you know but all of the
people that bear knuckles signed
they're kind of like on their way out
that him he could still be relevant in
the way classically
if hatred rachel isn't you know i'm
saying like those are two like they're
good they're good
but then they were they weren't top
level in the ufc
so they they went on you know they were
the chad was talking look at this yeah
that's what i'm saying yeah chad could
have sticked around he could have
started
boxing good bro like dude all the elk
that he's been killing like thank god go
straight through thank god he's retiring
giant traps there's jack i do so i've
i've worked out with that guy trained
with him for what like
four or five years and by far still to
this day the most athletic person i've
ever worked through
really by far chad chapman is for sure
should have been a ufc championship wow
if you would have had
some cardio yeah
i'm sorry i'm thinking of chad connor
like eight days yeah
jose aldo chad mendes
earth right now like what's this ufc
thing about show them chad mendez versus
jose aldo too they had like that last
where the bell rang and like yeah
like they even had like that couple
iconic little moments
and like oh what the [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm
getting some time was over or not
yeah yes i
strength too like we'd start in like
situations and he'd always [ __ ] win
the situation we'd even start like full
log like
worst case position like full lock
triangle
all you just posture out of it every
time he's just a beast he's just too
strong
it's insane the guy's uh he's a he's a
he's an animal that's a good guy did he
start
he started a company do you start a
company with clay guida they don't like
fishing slash like hunting companies he
does fins and feathers it's a guide
service
and they also do uh fishing as well too
they take you on like
hunting tours yes so i would do he has
like celebrity guided tours so i'm going
i was supposed to i've been on hunts for
him he's
on the term celebrity but yeah i was
supposed to go i was supposed to go on a
tuna trip three days after my fight but
i got knee surgery so i couldn't go
um but something like that went up on a
mule deer hunt so he like sends out like
five different guys and i hunt with
these guys i go and stay with them i
can't
how long is it it's like four or five
days i'm out yeah i'm thinking like a
day or two
i mean you i mean five days of like
camping live in the woods but dude i
mean some of these places are like
like nice ass like it's not the same
when you can't sleep in your porsche no
no this is
this this kind of guy if i can't fly to
four seasons i'm out yeah
this kind of camp is like a four
thousand square foot cabin
four thousand square foot gathering yeah
you're not liking it oh it's nice and
some of it's like very very and so you
just walk out
yeah they'll take you in a truck that's
more at brandon's valley yeah
he's in texas or something we just [ __ ]
all over so i have a mule deer hunting
in uh
utah he does oregon montana i'm sure oh
yeah
so definitely he finds these hunts
because of his name and what he's doing
and then he resells them to the public
to give them a deal to go and hunt with
himself
or my like me or paige van zanstein
hunts with him or like other does she
know how to hunt
i have no idea tell chad i'm [ __ ] in
dude i'll do that yeah i mean i don't
know how to shoot a gun but [ __ ] you you
learn yeah i'll talk about your air off
yeah i'll scare all the animals
he's like you can do the little horn
cook a mean [ __ ] steak
oh yeah that's a good idea that's what
chad's been doing yeah he's doing the
ass fins and feathers man he's been
doing a really good job with it
so he uh i pretty much
started fighting to feed his hobby and
his hobby was hunting
and now that he was doing good in hunt
um fighting
when he retired he's like turned hunting
into a job so he's doing what he does
he's doing it
murdering animals left and right yeah
yeah but dude
like to be honest like it's the most
ethical way to eat for sure
if you're gonna eat like when you go out
and buy something at the store
chick-fil-a
that animal yeah trees like like so good
camp so you can't have it yeah that's
what you're doing
before but then somebody broke
if more people would hunt there'd be
less like cruel teacher overall like
cattle and uh
[Laughter]
you don't you've never hunted before no
because that is i mean i grew up in
[ __ ] northern california you know
like like
bro yeah well so you know but you just
drove up in a different part
[Laughter]
no but it's something that i like after
like listening to people talk about it
on jerry i'm like that sounds [ __ ]
awesome i'm glad i do i just want to be
like a trek for like three [ __ ] days
yeah so i like doing like the [ __ ]
two week back country by myself
[ __ ] 20 mile hike back in the like
i like doing [ __ ] where i disappear my
phone don't work no one can get a hold
of me
like straight up like savage like me and
my brother my dad we go to idaho
we hike back take like a week's worth of
food with us
if we don't get nothing with a week
we're talking like beef drinking [ __ ]
like canned food we actually do we'll
take like we'll take fillet like so
the first stuff we take out there is
like all the frozen [ __ ] like the nice
fillets and the hamburger you make
spaghetti with and show off the campfire
yeah but eventually you eat through that
and then you guys are eating dehydrated
meals
yeah you know they taste good but
they're dog [ __ ]
my friends gave me [ __ ] because we went
camping and i brought a rotisserie
chicken that was fully cooked
no hell yeah yeah everyone wanted it you
know
yeah i'm sure eventually you guys ran
out of food then you know we do berries
and bugs and [ __ ]
we gotta we then we go back into town
yeah i can hike back into town for the
most part
we take enough food but i mean you're
only gonna be in the wilderness for so
like we're out there for a week i'd say
after a week
we haven't killed nothing because if you
kill something you have to come into
town but if you haven't killed anything
yet after a week i'd say we'd come back
in
but you have to like as they say you
have to address it like take like your
skin off and like
if you kill so we kill a elk i mean
you're bringing
800 pounds of meat you're carrying some
[ __ ] yeah but but don't you have to
where it is rogan was saying that you
have to dress it fast because the bear's
a smell
yeah for sure like montana yeah idaho
montana i'm in montana september man
so we won that round when we uh
kill it you gotta quarter it out yeah
fully skin it cut it into force
hang it in the trees put pepper all over
it white pepper
because the bees the meat bees will come
and destroy it oh interesting yes you
put pepper all over it cage control and
uh you gotta hang it high up in the tree
hopefully a bear doesn't even though she
kept
very comfortable kind of funny who who
had uh so i had two
i teach him one in the first and i had
t-shirt lose in the second so i think
it's one one going on in the third
has anyone been paying attention i just
like having keep glimpses
yeah yeah uh but i'm thinking i thought
i had a 1-1 i have one i think you have
a fight coming up soon
three weeks when three weeks oh damn
against
uh jj okay that'd be fun
yeah chilling who's j.j eldridge
ah okay okay okay she's a little stud
how do you feel i feel good yeah a
little tired just got off the plane
yeah where are you from where you live
arizona oh okay okay
you live here in la area yeah phoenix
are you in the huntington beach area
like costa mesa yeah
yeah because i think i'm at the gym too
yeah yeah because i used to go down and
train with when they were in the shitty
ass hole in the wall gym right there off
of uh ocean was it off ocean well i
don't know i never went to the church
do you still go to black house ever no
that's no thing
i'm old how old are you
thirty-eight well they used to have
everything yeah i've been out of the
game
yeah they used to own the one called
ultimate
all the time razor rob would fly me down
because razer and i fought reference
razor rock yeah
he's still
yeah do you know his name and [ __ ] he's
good yeah he's good
yeah he's good no he was working for the
ufc gyms for a while he's like one of
their top yeah
i don't think he is i think he's done
with it right now during right now he
maybe
brought him back on but or shane he put
him on i don't know as far as i know
he's still looking for him
got it got it because i talked to him
about it two months ago and said he
wasn't there forever
wc day yeah yeah i fought him in the wfa
i thought of one of his homies he was my
uh fighter coach
racer he was like the main guy holding
that because i was busy busing with my
coach
so tikki razor rob and
oh yeah cause basement dreamworld brady
was a juicy coach but they all show up
like
half hour late so drunk yeah but people
don't get something
coach yeah the coaches are experiment
right now like so we've never
been live we didn't practice at 10 a.m
really they'd be showing up straight at
like 10 a.m
yeah like it's still like glitter on
them and she's like man i never really
liked spearmint rhino i went to club
paradise
when i was on there you could always
tell when the coach went to spirit rhino
because rampage and rashad like
we're sparring today yeah yeah just sit
there and like watch it
like we sparred yesterday dude like shut
up
bro when uriah was coaching the fighter
it was me and lance palmer
they'd show up like that's my pizza is a
stud
he's so much fun i always have so much
we'd always show up with like an
eighteen pack
right today's sparring we'd be like
drinking beer while sparring dude just
like watching spark coach and talk [ __ ]
yeah they didn't show any of that stuff
on the like they don't know
that [ __ ] none of the fun stuff they
don't show you know be like getting
hammered and coaching
that you thought it would be like you
guys want to sell something this is
[ __ ]
yeah yeah they added all that nothing no
it's like professional athletes don't
drink where where do they
where do they where's the house now for
the kids is it still a dope house
uh they change it their house was
like airbnb now off of it was
it's airbnb yeah yeah yeah it literally
was
um well the house now is a [ __ ] it
was like two
two three exits from uh the strip the
apex
oh okay yeah going towards summer
there's like red rockers and then like
forgot it was a dope house though
it was cool we had a pool like some room
it wasn't my
in my opinion like when i saw the show
when you were on there and yeah
i was like dancing at a badass house
yeah the house i stayed at was oh they
put you in airbnb
yeah they play a station casino no they
put oh i was in the casino for a while
until they almost kicked us out because
but but did they put you in the gym but
we're at five in the morning
getting kicked out the [ __ ] the hotel
because it's my little brother
her myself and we start having a water
fight in the room
okay five in the morning five in the
morning okay all right
check this out that's our idea water
fight like water like
grab a [ __ ] water bottle and just
throw it all over the place like a
liquid death of the
yes yeah and then next you know like
we start going live and [ __ ] and my
brother did
how's your brother now 16. dude last
time i saw him was when we're on the set
of tax collector
[ __ ] remember that that terrible movie
we did
remember the worst movie in the world we
did i i mean i had fun
i had fun too but it was a bad movie
yeah it would
i i'm not gonna say no
it was fun though it was it was dope it
was different it was my first time i
ever did something like that it was cool
seeing shyla buff
like you didn't like him he was crazy we
had that [ __ ] remember like that's right
he wanted to fight
like he was so in character he would
like fight fight yeah i've heard his
life
like he tried fighting like the one we
slammed him on the table yes
do you remember when they had to cut
because he cut his hand because
so he was in a gang there's another guy
in another gang and we're at [ __ ]
craft service i'm eating like [ __ ]
chicken tenders
and he attacks the guy from the other
gang dude no we're not excused
he's he's like the stuff i'm sitting
down and they start fighting
and they're like brian break it up [ __ ]
like
my [ __ ] yeah they're playing touch [ __ ]
in the park
touched by the party then i was like
trying to kill them and then the next
day they try to keep them
away from each other and we're all
pissed off because he these two keep
looking at each other
and we're like come on man like we just
want to get the scene yeah because
stop the shoots oh for sure they have to
like get his angle this angle this angle
yeah you're like [ __ ] narcissus yeah
i love it
turns around and he starts talking [ __ ]
to the the guy and
[ __ ] it we snap and [ __ ] slam that
[ __ ] on the table
and then he tried to hit me like with
the gun and it went like this and it hit
conejo in the mouth remember
and quinea was like it was pissed yeah
so i was holding his hands and i was
like
choke him out and connell is choking him
like hey what the [ __ ] is going on
bro this is shia labeouf right indiana
oh
he's yeah but he's notoriously crazy
what like he's interested in his full
character
yeah alex baldwin had some issue with
him doing a play on broadway where he
was like
i didn't understand at the point at that
time i didn't you know i don't know [ __ ]
about he's a method actor dude yeah yeah
i don't understand
well he's got a real tattoo yeah got his
character's name tattooed on his
really stomach yeah i was like you know
this moves me at like 18 on rotten
tomatoes right
like and you have a tattoo yeah yeah
that's correct but your main takeaways
you're saying you got to get this angle
that and go and you have to realize like
how boring it's not
shooting a film and you have to keep the
same energy the whole time yeah
it's like get ready for this day where
you're going i was solid yeah that was
your first acting
yeah that's a real tattoo oh my god
that's him off keto he was on keto
on set there you go right there
with the glasses yeah yeah that was when
he was on that's true that's when he was
on set
that's right yeah yeah that's when he
was attacking and just the one on the
stomach
the ones on the left are really just
just his stomach just this one says
creeper
this character's name yeah you should've
got all of it dude you're crazy
remember when he put that bag on his
head and was like i'm not a celebrity
anymore
he's a oh those are real man like chin
if you google like
mark harley shia labeouf there might
have been like a movie player that i was
in where
i did something similar that's what you
did
it was crazy to me see how talented he
was remember spoiler alert movie's been
out for four years to suck my dick
remember when he uh when he had to die
in the movie
and they have to keep recreating the
scene when he gets shot
negro was shooting him and i uh shooting
him and then he has to pretend he's dead
i i wasn't there that day he went there
that's the final scene dude
seeing him act like that i was like holy
[ __ ] he is a good actor
and to see him do it over and over and
they'd be like from the hungover games
premiere
how many times some articles got written
about it
for 12 hours oh acting is terrible it
was awful
you've been in a couple movies now right
um no
not only that one uh it was i did a we
were like a part of la originals
okay yeah that and then i just did one
with
uh i take it easy no no no no no no no
they call me no i know it's like
[Applause]
it more like i'm a stupid [ __ ] like oh
no i feel you like i don't know anyone
i just know you by who you played like
when [ __ ] uh
like rdj that mickey ward guy
uh he was a fan and they hit me like hey
rdj wants to talk to you what the [ __ ]
is like rafael dos
like what the [ __ ] is rdj yeah yeah
uh robert downey jr oh wow so i'm just
talking about
iron man yes that's nice yeah okay so
i'm in the garage working out and they
said okay he's gonna face him what the
[ __ ] i like ten percent battery angle
also who faces
face i mean i was like oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] iron man
i was like hey what's up bro like oh hi
all right he's giving me advice for like
a fight or something
no i just talk actors are so [ __ ]
gone he's like all right bro i've been
watching a lot of your video
yeah no he was he was cool bro he was
just like hey i want to get to know you
and everything
oh weird and then uh get to know you
he was like where are you from i'm 28
bro
like say make a wish
i thought it was cool like i felt so
special i felt special
because he was a fan yes that's dope and
then uh
so [ __ ] get to know you those little
we both we both spent the night in the
same jail station before
so we kind of bonded off that right
different reasons though right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this was for some uh
you know mine was my super was really
stupid
uh those were back in the days though
dude he fully reinvented himself he's
crashing
yeah but yeah it's some tough days
anyways uh another special shout out
yeah i feel you that's my point uh yeah
great story though another special shout
out to sponsors tonight manscape the
official electric trimmer
of the ufc if you haven't tried the new
lawnmower 4.0
it's like a spaceship it's shaped like a
dick it's got a 400
or 4000k led light so you can navigate
it in the dark
and if you're shaving nuts in the dark
you got bigger problems uh you can trim
your balls body and even
your ass uh have your balls feeling like
they have zero gravity help your little
planet stay fresh with the sun's heat
with the performance package no one's
touched that dude yeah get you some look
at him go dude
he's doing it he's really doing it mark
will shave your head if you want
uh all thick boys tonight get 20 off and
free shipping with the code cfc
at menscape.com uh that's 20 off and
free shipping the code cfc at
menscape.com
we got the link in code in the bio okay
there we go yeah i remember when i was
shooting that show uh tax collector
and i thought it was like gonna be my
big breakout debut i was gonna be the
rock
and then they gave me a mask and i was
like oh i don't want to be in a mask
and i didn't know it worked like that
and so they gave me a gun that had a
mask on
and i was like i'm not wearing this
[ __ ] mess so i took it off i was
firing the gun here
cut like negro mask on i was like yeah
no doubt
put the mask on took it off just cut
negro where the [ __ ] mask i was like
nobody's gonna recognize me dude
got the [ __ ] mask in the movie so
unless you really know who i am can
barely see me in the movie though yeah i
get a mask on this
one and this my character wouldn't do
this because
yeah yeah i was wearing a [ __ ] mask
man
i dude i i got derek lewis man i got
i got to i woke up this morning i
thought dirk lewis he's a better odds
now but
i definitely think gaines is going to
win man win by submission
if dude derek lewis yeah no you can
still place the bat on draftkings
i bet all the time yeah yeah are you
everyone you bet on this one
i did put money on derek lewis now he's
even though the all week you've been
talking about how we got back
nuts for months i've done sill guns nuts
i just have this weird feeling derek
lewis gets done in his own
hometown he's so [ __ ] hard but
the thing about sarah gone it's like his
his footwork's so good and
if you look at his fight against
rosenstroke he doesn't get [ __ ] hit
but so to hear how much more he's derek
lewis has been training
just really makes me think how much he's
overthinking and did you hear derek
derrick lewis goes i'm just gonna i want
to be fight of the year and hopefully i
get a knockout i'm going at them
because that's the thing about cyril god
it's like he means you just sit back
he just picks you apart if you go no
one's really gone at him
yeah so we'll see yeah i don't know dude
that's crazy right because you were
talking to dc about the pressure did you
see that they had that similar
moment yeah wait pressure fighting in
his hometown and everyone being there oh
it's the worst you know there's many
fighting hometowns
like even when i do when i'm on the
comic tour if i go to denver you know
like so many people you like you better
yeah you're sleeping in your bed i
fought honda center and i fought yeah
forum yeah but isn't your whole family
and like aunts and uncles sitting up for
free tickets and [ __ ] oh dude
no no no majority
[Applause]
who's listening fighters get four
tickets maybe more if you're
a main event so it's still maybe six
don't [ __ ] happen
how much i get hooked though yeah
so what i did was i created i had so
um so i created like a a card you give
out and i had an assistant that i
basically paid and she just had all my
ticket sales
so i gave her i gave her 10 of whatever
she sold so if you still
would beltor give you more than four no
no i'm talking about when i was with
strikeforce oh
strike four stuff so right so okay
because i was in san jose yeah yeah so
san jose so we'd sell out that's like
your fight island yeah so it's like my
fight island so basically what i did i
handed out a card
business card it had her contact
information was for tickets only so her
phone would blow up boom ten percent so
you know
but i was selling 200 000 tickets she
was making damn damn
she's making good that was a great side
hustle yeah so it was because bellator
gives you 12 percent of whatever yeah
[Music]
yeah i was selling [ __ ] tickets on
the side of the freeway yeah when you
first started on the way to my fight
yeah
yeah hey [ __ ] hold up go [ __ ]
i'm parked right on the 405 and 110 like
yeah
yeah yeah like [ __ ] like dude you're
late what the [ __ ]
do you remember
you remember your fight before you got
the ufc when i was in the back with
you the when you were warming up
you and and uh no they didn't fought too
on the same card remember he was the
main event you were like co
i think no i was the main event no dear
usual right no no
that was respecting that was a title
fight that's right you were the main man
that was respecting the cage that's
right
after was elephant yes that's right you
went yeah
yep i was nervous i was like hey bro uh
having fun in a while yeah it's just you
and me in the back yeah i was like what
the [ __ ] do i do
yep i said because like i didn't fight
for a while but it was two years before
five yeah he had a little bit of great
in his beard and it was off to the
[ __ ] legs
like i couldn't believe when i come out
the beginning of the round for like the
first minute you're doing all right man
yeah i'm doing all right yeah i mean i
i've actually tried to look up tate on
instagram
to thank him personally who's this tate
the corner
in the corner he [ __ ] saved me
because i got cut in the second round
and i could not [ __ ] see yeah worse
could have all done but when i came out
for the first minute of every round
i like gold yeah i noticed that i'm like
oh they actually stopped the [ __ ]
but then you just rub the vaseline off
and [ __ ] happens you start bleeding your
eye again
but it does give you something like the
reason why they didn't stop that fight
is because tate was able to keep that
[ __ ] under control
you know they were thought in the second
round we'd have to rematch a bunch of
[ __ ] i was like
thank you awesome man yeah jesus christ
yeah uh if you are betting
dope as a human being too yeah yeah it's
a good joke dude yeah yeah how good are
those [ __ ] liquid deaths yeah
another one yeah i'm drinking beers
yeah right it looks like a beer if you
show up to the gym and everyone's like
oh he's drinking beer before he benches
that's cool
it's just water it's just water kids uh
if you are a betting man michael kiesa
is an underdog and i
hear you and i have money on him wow i
better i think
yeah i bet on him too he's so big i saw
him when he was fighting 55
ran into him one time i was like 55 [ __ ]
do you make 55. i was like good
god i'm standing next to him like
speaking of being
are we still in the same way he's the
biggest 45 of all time
right not anymore you're enormous who
else is there who's bigger
max is my height holloway yeah yeah but
but he doesn't have that well
no he gets pretty big man max hit him up
about 1805
yeah [ __ ] yes i got up to 1910
let's not do that it's so funny hey my
first thing
my first in the ufc joe you said rogan's
turn all the time oh josh
the probably the biggest [ __ ] 55
pound i've ever seen i look at the 55
pounders now
god i should be like a 35 pounder what
the [ __ ]
guys are enormous man well there's this
other guy too who uh
who is it um is it b is he is he is six
two bro
that's crazy he's standing here he's
standing here standing here
his brother's good his brother fights
for bellator
he did i think he's i don't think he's
gone yet allegedly he looks like a
hormone
yeah he's bro his brother's good too you
know exactly what i'm talking about
yes he looks like the hormones
we have we have a thing with like a mask
yeah i love that gentleman whoa that's
just my [ __ ]
so yeah zabeet i think retired he's out
but yeah you're doing yaya rodriguez for
smacks
why though why did he retire i think he
was just sick of this [ __ ]
i don't know because he's a stud yeah
he's
like he's hoping though right he's got
cove and i think he's just [ __ ] done
with it but mark henry before
the beat was like anything mark henry's
coach who i trained with trained me for
my cro cop fight
he was like dude i'm telling you you
need to talk about this is a beat kid
yeah he's in our gym
he [ __ ] up everything yeah like really
he's like he's a
freak yeah and sure enough he's he's a
beast from what i see his brother's good
he's dead yeah yeah yeah his brother
fights in bellator just had his first
fight bro
yeah younger brother yeah does he look
like him he's not as tall
i think he fights at 35. harry not a
snow that was harry
i don't know why that matters yeah it
turns you on we get it i'm just trying
to
yeah we got some landscapes yeah yeah
it's a beat needs manscape
i'm very excited for this fight this
this is technically
probably the best find the card if
there's gonna be a five tonight it's
gonna be this one unless derrick lewis
can get a knockout
this has five night written all over it
and if chiesa gets him down
it's [ __ ] gamer he's a monster yeah
bruce buffalo
he got into it coach paul oh really yeah
oh he's on he was coaching another team
because he had a teammate on there or
something right
coach paul i love you is it hearing him
talk about how he gave up [ __ ] talking
like i figured he was he was being
interviewed
although i saw that too i think it's a
mission radio yeah yeah i love those
guys
yeah he's like you know he's like i just
realized it wasn't me
for a while he was like talking [ __ ] and
he was like i just thought it was the
thing to do
he lost the fight and his coach was like
dude quit talking [ __ ] just yeah it's
not your thing
there's a thing where they fought right
or or the
kevin kevin lee yeah don't talk about my
mom yeah
i thought it came across i love that
chiesa
in uh gaijin commercial have you seen
that it's such a good commercial
so so good is that what what is that
that's for i don't know
like beer or something wasn't it a
medela commercial it's mo
no it's not going down all the limes
right so it's like it's got to be some
sort
it's for tequila right or something
because they both they're both what's
that
what's the commercial it's really well
done though
yeah it's a really good commercial i
don't know
so it's not that great i never want to
be that guy be like yo jamie pull it up
but i just did it right there sorry
it's all good it's okay no volume though
we can't oh [ __ ] i wish it was fun but
that's how it looks dude
versus champions yeah it's tequila
it's it was it's [ __ ] great man
dude if i see you on one more toyo tire
commercial i'm gonna freak the [ __ ] out
when you got the acting chops i'm sure
it's not it's not cheap to keep those
[ __ ] tires on the jeep
that's true well those aren't toyo's
he's lying right now like those big
monster trucks
yeah they make those oh wow wow that's
what i got on my truck too toyota's yeah
well you what you have a you look like a
raptor raptor that's just that's about
it
is it tuned oh yeah yeah yeah i went
through your boy dude
oh you went through my guy yeah oh type
movement i sent you to him that's right
yeah greg's great yeah he's awesome dude
yeah
yeah got me a sick ass deal bought out
of state he works with canelo everybody
good job aunt
or your raptor mm-hmm in utah uh
i bought it for the east because you
know in utah right they have their whole
facility there so you have a full on
track you can go there and test drive it
it's like a full experience for a whole
weekend yeah but you got to fly to
[ __ ]
you go to utah and they have their their
headquarters there you just drive like
they they running through tracks they
have you jump the cars
it's all free just
you have a defender the the only thing
it does is
really that's probably smart but well a
good player
good player board sometimes i'm still
looking at one more
what what are you like travis barkley
you like the old school [ __ ]
i have two i have two classics 63 impala
yeah but they're gonna do nothing to go
up in value those are sick ass
investments
bro the only car you should buy should
be a classic car
yeah i have a driver yeah yeah
i have 85 el camino and a 63 super sport
and then the jeep
so you have three jeep and then now we
invested in real estate or
registered yeah no real estate yeah it
was he's so worried about the takedown
yeah he's so worried about the takedown
he's the main thing that's why the main
thing is real estate smart
yeah kiasa nix that's
if i look at him like how the [ __ ] did
you ever make 55 like how big he is
gosh man it's like anthony rumble oh
[ __ ]
no i just tripped on the fence mainly
manly tripped on the fence
yeah the right hook had nothing to do
with it you don't look
game is so good it's good here's my pick
for draftkings dog
good pick here we go he's underdogs
he's got it i wouldn't say i don't know
yet you don't think so no not yet not
yet
he's 55 yeah he's got a whole reason
he's got a real hard time with guys like
with guys like covington and guys like
video can't take him down he can't take
his men down not with that wrestling's
gonna jab the [ __ ] out of him
no yeah look i'mma kiss a fan i just i
don't i don't think he's here right now
oh yeah look at this guy
i love shisha too is he this is not
where he wants to be again oh
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh no
[ __ ] no no no no no go go go go you
don't have it
that's a black belt son oh oh oh oh no
no no never kevin kevin he caught him
kevin lee caught him this is [ __ ]
tough
oh [ __ ] your next champion huh no way
nope not anymore damn
yeah yeah apparently yeah
right if he's not they need to give it
to him
damn well yeah that the road to the
title is going to be tough wow minor
step back [ __ ]
well i apologize for anyone i convinced
to bet on i would have been on that
fight i'd better
out about yesterday you guys heard it
here first though do not vote
do not bet on derrick lewis he's been
popping derek
that one's a dude as a dog and his power
because if you're gonna make money on a
fight you gotta take the dog well
especially when you've been talking up
gain all yeah
and then you're like oh my god
i did not see him getting choked up
well dude vicente lu the winner of this
is i mean
right there could you you look at the
queue at 170. what do you finish
he knocked out woodley remember they
were exchanging yeah he knocked out
woodley yeah
how do you feel about the like jake paul
you got covington burns
like leon edwards those are the top
three stephen thompson
when i see people getting money that's
what that's why i see vicente lucas
[Music]
and you when you look at it
like some things that they have said
it's almost raising awareness and some
other [ __ ] that people don't have no
idea about like jake paul's going hard
on the paint on fighter pay which i'm
like dude yeah
keep going keep going you guys can't
talk about that yeah
let's not get this guy's in trouble
three of you can't yeah i can't but i
can't yeah you can't do it i
talk hella [ __ ] uh but do they get the
viewers that's what i was
like you can talk as much as you want
they're gonna get paid because they're
literally elaine
they're they're getting the viewers no
but i'll say this all
that stops if jake gets starch by
woodley
all this youtube crossover [ __ ] yeah
it's done it comes with a screeching
halt yeah i don't know
dude i like it i always say [ __ ] like
that but then they come up with some
other [ __ ] that gets you be like did you
see what the [ __ ] you did
right you're always like if this happens
like they're done
and then they'll do some way out of not
like i'll say this like
[ __ ] from left no i'll say this brian
like there's like youtubers can fight
other youtubers i'm saying as far as him
cross-pollinating with
ufc like real fighters i think that's
out the window if he gets starched who
knows
he might [ __ ] with another legit fighter
and then people
he's gonna make his he's gonna make his
way up though so if he beats woodley
he'll go to the next level dude
i bet he fights connor i would imagine
probably that's your biggest money
because do you think connor kind of has
how many fights left
after nate what is their form yeah what
are you gonna do as far as my thing
was if you're gonna fight if you're
gonna fight jake paul like you have to
figure out
what way it's gonna be at jake paul's
big he's big compared to connor
connor walks around let's say he walks
around 82 84.
yeah jake paul walks around 205 190.
that's small yeah logan's a bigger one
yeah i know logan's a bigger one but i'm
saying like he's still he's 1990
you still want anything logan's connor's
timing for jake paul would [ __ ] him up
so bad though
oh yeah you would think you would have
you would [ __ ] hope
but who knows it's like but the other
thing with jake it's like the only thing
we have to go off of is he starts
spending aspirin right yeah it's not we
don't have a lot
of sample size there you're right we
don't have a big sample size on it but
the power that he possessed to do that
not a lot of guys have that power in in
small gloves not a lot of guys have that
power
i agree the thing though you got if you
are a guy fighting jake his timing is
what yeah
anyone who has a trained eye you see his
timer like [ __ ] that kid can kind of
fight
him you fight he's got some skill he's
dedicated to a world champion but he's
gonna
be canelo but he's up like the woodley's
and these other guys coming after him
like
if you don't train seriously he's gonna
[ __ ] yeah all this [ __ ] is fun man it's
a bunch of kimbo and dadas i love it
this is entertainment exactly we're here
to make money
i'm doing a fight campaign for it for
god's sake yeah when you look at
what are they called uh those type of
fights
circuses no no no like uh [ __ ] shows
these money grabs celebrities sign me up
i'm sorry i'm not gonna run that option
here right help
they're all exhibition fights yeah so
not the jake paul ones though jake pawns
are real fights right
no the whoa all the television fights i
feel like or i don't know oh
that's the way they go again with floyd
was exhibition
jake's fights are a real fight they're
real fighters
logan against mayweather was that with
an exhibition
how do you guys see aldo pedro munoz
dude if you watch all those last few
like even against uh [ __ ]
peter yanni look good man yeah that's
good yeah i mean like because we think
stuff because we've been watched what
but but dude he's the same age as pedro
yeah he just has some miles on him he's
been [ __ ] fighting so damn well i
think pedro
wins he has more power for sure he's
just durable
i think i think i think if he just
started together so i like i always go
with the one i know
yes yeah
it was like all you guys were like the
top notch and like we were like the ones
pedro wasn't really fighting that time
he's like just the cheapest barely from
brazil
yeah i think he's i think he's got
better cardio guillotine remember that
yeah
great chain great cardio i think he wins
the fight jose
uses his kids he wins i think he wins he
hasn't used it
he's going to walk his time a little bit
against uh peter but it wasn't enough to
like make a difference he was tired
he looked he got tired and peter took
over the fight for so long
when i heard like i heard he got like in
a motorcycle accident ever since then
yeah someone said that you can't kick
anymore because someone's kicked his
legs i think it's because he has
two thousand fights well i just yeah
he's just it's gonna catch up with him
and i'm kind of wondering like if he has
the same type of like aging that they do
in cuba where he's probably like 50
because he looks like he's almost 50.
he's like says he's 32. he owns a
cheeseburger joint in uh brazil
he owns a soccer team he owns a soccer
team he has a soccer team in brazil
yeah he's like he's a majority owner of
a soccer team soccer team's like nine
dollars out there but yeah
i don't know here in brazil bro they're
pretty good
it's like nine dollars yeah i'm gonna
buy seven teams yeah
uh [ __ ] bread
yeah but we we think of jose aldo being
so old but him and [ __ ] pedo are the
same age as pedro hasn't
fought as long oh is that the [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh cody garbrandt that's the
highlight or no
i think they're trying to mix in a movie
and this is this this is you and
volkanowski is it
it's got to be what's wrong dude have
you seen that volcanowski
oh what's up dog okay hey can we bring
the long hair back or not i'm trying to
okay i'm trying to dude you you got your
hair's too good not to make it long dude
when you shaved i was so disappointed
yeah yeah you did it for a long time
i remember i was with you like threw
your phone at the phone i broke
my phone my phone was broke because you
cut your hair my phone is cracked right
now
what all right so what do you do you're
like you're growing it out yeah
you're growing it out but what you can
do with it during the fight though
you're gonna braid it oh yeah yeah some
braids
what dude i'm gonna get out of there
short hair seven
harsh so hard [ __ ]
up dude with those eyes along here what
are we doing dude
those [ __ ] eyes along here brendan's
ruthless when it comes to the race
with long hair dude because i got three
babies by the way
i got three babies by the hair i i got
two already
yeah she's like we're out of control she
was yeah maybe there's somebody put the
tip
in oh i got three babies by the tip
let's play a game just to do it
just let me see if it fits yeah
i'm so curious how uh how uh nick diaz
is gonna look
yeah i think i hope he looks good i
think he's gonna look good
he's one of my favorite fighters i hope
it looks like everyone likes the deal
but here but both of them are our
favorite fighters like the two of them
were [ __ ]
just like legends they were going to
match them up against rapidly because
that was not in the conversation
before if they announced it but then
you're like oh no it was always in the
conversation piece the problem was
though they just
the ufc was kind of outside of the
conversation the fans were thinking you
know what i would have done if i'm the
ufc i do
nick versus jorge because right it's
like i'm getting revenge for my little
brother
jorge needs a fight like dude that would
be so much but i think you used robbie
as a
he's like one of those fights like hey
you don't know what nick said
my little brother [ __ ] like i'm
a big bro but why isn't
jorge fighting [ __ ] covington
why is that fight not happening because
i'm trying to fight cover just trying to
fight for the title yeah
dude it's crazy though that fight for
sure happened
all right call them out yeah you're big
enough dude
yeah yeah look they didn't look the same
weight class at all
dude he used to be 270 pounds do you
know that played bro
yeah he used to be like 200 he used to
be so thick have you ever seen him when
he was like super pokemon
i'm sure he was on a super bowl right
he's on the [ __ ]
yeah no way bring up how thick he used
to be
i'm telling he was like 240 i know but
that little bastard's not [ __ ]
getting
his legs were like [ __ ] i know a
creatine user when i see one
[Laughter]
so don't go saying he's all natty he's
taking that there he's on that creek
protons you want to see mark sweat
mentions
legit look at him though though
jacked that's what two
he was 240
go where his face is all fat like mine
right there
damn tj funny comments somebody left on
my page was uh he's like you should you
should uh fight tj for the bantamweight
title i'm like look i can cut down on
short notice it's just getting past
usada with all the craziness
you saw as a [ __ ] bro yeah you ain't
gonna do it
danny's thick boy he said i know you've
been pretty
what's that
oh damn she's pretty though i'm not sure
if that's his wife you have kiddos too
yeah yeah that had that was a chicken
she's
flats too she's wearing firewood heels
she's like you can't just take them off
you don't want to slip those off for the
picture with my belt or
shaking i'll leave them on like like get
slightly behind me work some angles
did you have him beaten uh holloway uh
which one did you even watch him or not
they didn't even
second one yeah yeah i had holloway win
the lost the first one won the second
one yup okay cool
first one he lost his leg kicks correct
yeah
holloway versus uh [ __ ] uh with the
mexican kid's name
yeah oh nice yeah that's going to happen
what's happening or his chill calls him
no something happened right yeah what's
up
something might have happened he's out
again i think it was out hollow he got
injured
hallway or oh you might be right hallway
backed up bro got injured i think yeah
i thought i loved holloway man because i
remember uh
watching something like on ig yeah he
might be right
no so far nothing it's in the work for
the main event four days yeah four days
ago
four days ago that's a great fight yeah
oh it's still straight i think holloway
beats
the [ __ ] out of a [ __ ] thing the
first fight was it was called off
because of an
injury or something okay that's first of
all yeah you're just not active enough
yeah you're right because it was
supposed to happen
though for sure no but yeah
so athletic dude nuts yeah i wish i
could steal some athleticism
if i could take your brain putting out
here yeah dude we're going on we're
going
to stop about taking you're unstoppable
mm-hmm
i want to stream your brain like the
movie get
yeah cause i just went because i'm mean
as [ __ ] yeah you're an [ __ ]
for sure hundred percent you gotta be
yeah i've heard stories monster
tiki was afraid to put me in here
together actually for a bit
yeah yeah how crazy to see pedro at
the level he's at now because when we
started yeah black house he was just a
guillotine like jiu jitsu coach me and
him were i was 18 and he was
super young i was 18 and he was 19 20.
how do you know uh 30. nice
and we're [ __ ] both you guys are
[ __ ] crushing it yeah we went to
respect to the cage together
we went to lfa together went to ufc
together
nuts you guys don't still train together
do you no
he's in he where's he at brazil yeah
he's in florida yeah
he's in florida we train we never really
even train together
just roll we trained when we were 18 for
a bit yeah and then me and him
like to just rock and sock them robots
yeah
and then uh who's this me and pedro
[ __ ] what 12 years ago now he said he
seemed like a nice guy
yeah i talked to frankie edgar and i was
like he's like a really good guy frankie
and i were really good friends and
frankie was telling me he's like hey
yeah because
i was i was 18. he was fresh from brazil
so we both had some approve
i wanted to prove that i belong at black
house he you know like he want to make a
statement
like we had some dogs at blackheads yeah
we would just rock and suck
it was just sparring i learned no
technique yeah you're just gonna get in
there and you just [ __ ] spark it was
nuts
that's crazy yeah yeah anderson silva
machida you guys were aka
was there you were there jake maybe jake
ellenberg i think was jake would be in
there yeah
that's right uh that [ __ ] was called
sinister it wasn't even called blackout
did you try that
pat cummings yeah yep monsters great
clip of islam aka chef like
manhandling that ca state champ or the
national like high school
champions kid wrestle for dc and uh
you're right
he's like this is [ __ ] like flip
something yeah
is it ak yeah was it aka the california
champ kid
like talking no no they were just he was
a young kid came in he was he was a
senior that year he was getting ready he
ended up winning state that year he's a
stud
yeah he came in and mocked chelsea
having the real russian tie just [ __ ]
just
oh dude i told you hit the russian whip
down you can pull it up you can play
chase uh saldana say i think his name is
but it's on youtube as well he just he
rush and whips him down they make him
inside wrist tie and just [ __ ] whips
him down the ground back on the mat and
he's like oh
[ __ ] and like like you know
get that [ __ ] i want that [ __ ] that
kid's fourteen though and that could be
no no national champion no
state champs he plays the michigan state
right now oh he's that much like a
full-ride scholarship
[ __ ] yes look right there
used it boom [ __ ] you use it after they
go did you they announced mike chevro's
uh
i told you ah that's the fight bro it it
kind of is but
it's come on he's going to walk through
him man but but
we need him to get more yeah he's going
to walk through him though but that's
what we want i know because if he
struggles at that then we know he's not
there
he has trouble one take down mocks the
floor i think one or two
a [ __ ] night yeah he's just too big
for him man so all my friends were like
why aren't they doing like
why isn't his own facing why isn't shawn
o'malley and it's like
that's not that's not the same the
business of it well i mean like i'm just
using these two guys yeah
people who will be like why aren't they
facing like it's good they're building
top five no
yeah but if you if you pull up the
rankings though there's no really for
him to fight because
everyone's already matched yeah we went
through this last time we had the guys
in the top top
the last fight no it airs on uh on food
truck diary with you and big
oh that's right yeah you got into it was
that aaron throws that dropping thursday
yeah yeah
we broke into a lot with about our show
on that which was nice we talked about a
lot and big john just
i had all these ideas on judging and
stuff and big john just shut me down
you forget bro
welcome to my world and try having a
conversation with that guy on our show
and like no no it should be like this
he's like no no let me tell you why he
just breaks
like josh step-by-step i was like big
john yeah hear me out here standings are
coming over
they're boring there's grapple knees to
down opponents yeah
make it happen dude he shut me down so
far no he's like his own business
oh then he breaks like how to get those
laws passed
yeah like all right dude you're no [ __ ]
yeah i love your argument
about islam the other day that you have
with big john oh yeah
yeah he's [ __ ] oh like the first 10
fights
yeah so like a little bit with big john
on that but i also think
i think you know i think islam is going
to be champ like yeah but you have to
you have to i
the reason why i'm saying with islam is
that you have to look it with khabib
right
his style is just go forward islam will
stand and make the fight a fight
he's just striking yes and he'll but he
will just take people just
dominate the position from top to bottom
he's the most dominant champion that's
ever walked the face of them by far by
far
there hasn't been more one that's been
more dominant agree okay so when you
talk about islam right he will make the
fight a fight
but he stylistically for most people in
fact he's a yeah he hasn't had more of
an entertainment factor than he has
possesses
because his striking is better because
his striking's better but his
submissions took
out that even a chance of you knocking
him out like he was just
well not only that but what made could
be popular wasn't so much that he was
such a dominant wrestler it was his
ground up
and the way he would talk [ __ ] to people
because the way like even with mike
he was telling barboza the same [ __ ]
he's like yo it's my destiny just tap
give up
you're not going to get away from me i'm
going to [ __ ] smash you i have to
fight
yes i have to fight for the title it's
my destiny he did the same thing michael
johnson did the same thing to barbara
doesn't see connor double down on the
comments no jesus yeah oh dude i
i wouldn't i thought about it right now
but i just shut the [ __ ] up because i
don't know
i should have brought it up no it's like
and i'm dude i love congratulations
but it's like oh bro what are you doing
hey i'm just letting you know the ship
sailed man i can't i can't even fall in
line with that
i can't i can't fight oh my god
i don't i don't i don't i think it's
like desperate now it's like oh no it's
not even fun dude yeah there was a
moment that press conference where
dustin's like you used to be way better
at this
that was yes the best well i thought the
best line was
what was it conor fast actually connor
sleep
mcgregor you're fast mcgregor's sleeping
it's also tough because
could be beat the [ __ ] out of him you
know what i'm saying like if it was like
a really really
close fight i'm like alright well let's
get let's get back into like when we
were trouble with
brenda you and i had this conversation
before when we said oh when they fight
could be stand up it's going to be too
bad this and that remember i'm like
conor dick right yeah
but these were the heydays of congress
and i was like you can't hold that
against me
i said i did say oh no i'm gonna hold it
against you because now time has passed
i'm gonna be doing some [ __ ] like that
yeah but now that brian's here remember
i said the worst matchup for khabib
is brian remember that sorry bro like i
disagree and then [ __ ] could be
gonna beat me and then you'd be like i
[ __ ] you could be nothing
no but what do you think about it
because this is the
only reason why i say this and i and
as a martial artist martial artist i
would love that fight for myself
yeah of course because i know it would
no you want to test yourself but not not
even detest yourself
bro this is the reason why he's been
wrestling his entire life
and he's been on top of people his
entire life yeah my entire life
i've had the gracies on top and beating
the [ __ ] out of me
big and then for the grappling aspect
that's it
put it this way even if it's like i
wouldn't like all right let's say [ __ ]
you brian he'll never fight like i would
just love to grapple with the guy no and
it's more of like a it doesn't come from
a place of of oh i want to fight him or
beat him nothing
it comes from a place like yo
i want to see what i have yeah of course
and because this guy
plays just like we we dance the same
rhythm in different ways
we [ __ ] he's a top guy i'm a bottom
guy
and i get i get
i get i've been shooting submissions
from my back hey
[Applause]
but people forget people forget look
even though even though he even though
he did even though he could be such a
dominant wrestler his jiu jitsu from the
bottom as well as his all of his other
submissions
they're khabibs he all of his
submissions are they're very good
no i'm not saying they're not he's not
brian but what i'm saying what i'm
saying though is he's just as good off
the bottom as he's on top
but no one could put no one but people
have and that's the thing like how do
you know
i've trained with him for seven years
captain aka one of them but you know i
cornered him for four or four or five of
his fights when he starts calling him
so i guess i've trained with him for
years he's not he's brown or taken up
from the bottom
no not for the no but he's not also not
someone that stays there he doesn't hit
submission from the bottom what he does
he sweeps you to get on top and that's
how he gets your suggestions
he is not in terms of submissions from
the bottom that's not his game but let's
not let's not be mistaken and that's
what i'm saying
jiu jitsu is not the same it's been
proven it's not the same
okay and i'm not trying to just i'm not
trying to discredit jujitsu
but the samo fighters they've been doing
jiu jitsu for
decades for the generations of this okay
sure has been around but just to just
one aspect of fighting
[ __ ] is a mixture of what mma was
before yeah so
we're just saying khabib on top brian on
the bottom yes brian also doesn't move
like traditions
i i can understand i don't have
like and and when i say like that like i
said earlier right now
you might as well i didn't even i didn't
i didn't even i didn't even know you
[ __ ]
were you know yeah i get it i don't know
[ __ ] about this old people i get it
no no no no no no i didn't know you're
training with them bro i don't know
anything about
one and what gyms are yeah yeah i gotcha
i don't watch fights like pedro's dude
is a good like my ocean is just like
what if there's a guy that i would love
to fight
bucket lift like he [ __ ] me up or not
yeah it would be him
of course i
when i watch his interviews i [ __ ] with
what he said
yeah everyone is legit when he speaks
people listen i [ __ ] like what he
says i love what he's about
i love the way he conducts himself i
love the [ __ ] that he says he's a true
pro
he's a true pro and he's he's in my
opinion
like i like to i would want to think
yeah
like him because he would be he some
situations would happen
and the way he had words about it no no
the way he is
i'm talking about
and i go damn bro like he said what i
thought but he
he said it better yeah yeah he's not
yeah he's great
i know he like his heart is from a heart
it's from he's a good
he's a really good person and a good
person he does a lot of good stuff for
his communities yeah he's doing a lot of
great stuff for like dude
all the guys that he's trained with
these come up and even when i saw like
sure that they're connor
taking care of us when i saw even when i
saw the condition and i saw like
uh what his father said yeah i don't
know if you saw the interview
yeah yeah yeah yeah he goes i'll have
him over at my house that's when i said
you know what
that's where like yeah because that's
why every time he says something they'll
ask him about stuff and he goes he'll
explain his thoughts and he goes that's
just my opinion
yeah that's from my opinion yeah i think
that's why the connor stuff's so cringy
it's like god dude you're [ __ ] with a
good guy
yeah yeah yeah and he beat you dude yeah
that's the other one yeah i'm just i'm a
fan of the guy
yeah who's not it's hard not to be
though it's hard not to be and then like
when we were both in ufc i was like uh
my fight i'm so like
and then like after that like the more i
watch i go dude like i [ __ ] with this
he's a good dude like he's a good dude
but if you guys do if you guys do do a
submission thing
you and i bet on it huh all right i'm
down thousand bucks
how much you said you walk around 180 no
no that was way back like that's when i
was a fat piece of [ __ ] yeah what's up
how much you walk around now at 160.
that's the thing he walks around 190.
he's out of shape
he is never out of shape bro he's
sparring with these guys right now we're
getting ready for fights he's never out
of shape
that [ __ ] man he's watching
everybody's walking he's running
around all the great ones they like he's
just saying that he's the same thing oh
he doesn't wake up he trains
in the trouble he does the joke right
like in terms of like he's training all
the time
he's probably training twice a day over
jon jones going backwards because he's
so
dominant and john like no i don't i i
feel like
the dominant group is fighting yeah you
can see two different things
i agree with him on the different
conversations one is the most dominant
champion ever and the other one is the
most talented
and then the longer longer that's the
thing long right they're just two
different people yeah
i'm usually on the side of john you win
in march technical like
like everybody's good at everything yeah
so the the talent level's so much higher
could be dominated at a better the most
dominant division
and really never lost a round maybe
quinte give him maybe one no no he
jumped
out there
he lost apparently he lost one round to
um to conor supposedly but then someone
said he also lost a round to
um glycemic they said that you need him
for one round the first round the who
said that
the judges
the same yeah he was like i'm knocking
break your arm yeah i'm not gonna hurt
you because i know you're gonna tap so
i'm just gonna put you to sleep i don't
win the first round huh 10-9 i don't
think so
i i just saw a tweet i thought mate i
thought uh munoz won the first round
now remember when khabib said beginning
of year you tap like chicken
oh that was a good good good good this
is crazy oh man
i think uh aldo looks better the second
round though although it will stay
more disciplined and then but he's too
patient
yeah but pedro will will uh go more into
that
like [ __ ] it let's bang like watch right
here damn he's so good
pedro will like see the technical yeah
and then pedro will probably blitz him
in if he gets frustrated
with the technical pick man if aldo
kicks don't change the game
he's too tired i'll go in that third
round but he gets tired yeah he gets
tired
right there all the wins we could be
seeing now
although you know this time next year
it's gonna be dope just putting it out
there
oh [ __ ] this is 35 bro yes i forgot
he was so dominant he was so dominated
45 that he was someone going to 55.
and then now here he is at 35. he looks
like he's slowing down right now
he will do what he always is he always i
wish he could five-round fight you knew
it's kind of like coming right this
can't be a boxing match he he always
like wins the beginning of the rounds he
has a beautiful with with the power of
his leg kicks and with the calf kicks
changing the game i'm surprised he's not
just going to the well on him
he's so quick and so good right here i
heard him take that
kick down the right hand god [ __ ]
jose's fast man
oh i gotta throw some punches to set
that one up mm-hmm
it's crazy to think that he looks like
he's about 50. like he's [ __ ]
he's younger than me what is he 32 34
34.
my wife's like i can't believe all those
younger knows already dude
this year i turned 30. 30 30. [ __ ]
you're in the prime man
you are yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was sad that it goes fast man it was
way too fast
it's the best part i remember being 22
that 27 to 32
years 28 years old being a champion yeah
[ __ ] yeah
i'm 35 old as [ __ ]
at least you're a champion [ __ ]
i gotta get there still getting it bro
there's a leg kick there was one go to
the calf though keep going on the
[ __ ] leg
twice yeah he's just some good body
shots that body shot's
nasty yeah there's some dogs jose's a
dog even if he wins this it's like what
do you do yeah i feel like right now
i think right now in the sport 135 is
the stat most division
in all of the shows
or did is pitbull retire no uh the
i think what what pippa wants him to do
is pimple wants him to fight his brother
patricki first to fight before he fights
him because he's the champion 55
which makes sense go ahead and try and
you know fight my brother if you pass my
brother fifty-five
fifty-five yeah i get it you gotta
you gotta have he has never fought at
55. yeah i know i know he's a champ of
45 but he's only one little fight
there's other fights for him also in one
fourth
[ __ ] him and adam works would be a
[ __ ] great fight adam
stud good stand-up fighter just dog all
the way around
there you go stay bro what's your take
on aj
you know what he don't watch fights aj
mckee i just saw the highlight yeah
uh he's good he's cool every time i've
seen him he's being cool yeah he's i
don't watch his confidence
athletic yeah he's from long beach yeah
i see little things where like i guess
like i didn't think so either he was
talking and stuff but
i i knew the speed would be a factor
when he bought patrice when he fought
pit bull
but i mean it was a normal cross kick
though yeah but it was the height man is
the speed the speed is going to set it
up though
every time you do the jab he actually
tried to parry the jab and that's what
happened he threw the straight the young
lion
head kick came up right after yeah yeah
he's a young lion
i feel like patricia was almost like
where the the outdoor situation is right
yeah
dude no they i've rolled with
them korean zombies
so santa like when they when they come
down was they to fight with them
then after that they came right back for
one of their other fights and then they
came over my gym and trained it with me
for a little bit for the week of their
fight
they're good people they're [ __ ]
really good people
they're family i love the kids are so
great you see the kids running around
all fight week it's [ __ ]
it's nice to be here you see the kids
running around so fun you see the wives
all stressed
out you know but but no great i just
feel like
he's he's been doing it for so long he's
been the champ
he's got the most wins the most
knockouts the most everything in
bellator it's like dude you've been
doing for so long
you know you got a kid who's 16-0 now
but like
he's young yeah just coming up yeah yeah
young speed athletic
everything's approved everything
everything you know and not to mention
his dad was
a [ __ ] that was a bad badass
[ __ ] that was really good
antonio [ __ ] he just fought out the
longer he's still mad at him his dad
followed the same card as him yeah he
wanted to be the first
father-son to fight on the same card
yeah you know i think i love what they
got going on yeah it's crazy
bro i met her and i was like you trying
to poison my eyes or something like
you were who you worked for oh
[ __ ] how'd you guys meet oh [ __ ]
oh no okay another time yeah
[Laughter]
oh tinder huh i feel like we're on a
blind date tell us how you guys met
tell me how you met a blind date
this shit's great yeah she shot her shot
shoot her shoes
did he have long hair or bald hair long
hair long hair oh okay okay
okay
she catfished your ass that's funny i
look like all them
that's [ __ ] great
world thinks i shot my shot
i wish he would just kick man if alder
if aldo would kick and set up his his
hands a lot more
i guess the the buzz around is that he
something's going on with like yeah
he wouldn't kick it yeah he wouldn't
kick yeah something with his like his
foot or his shin he's got something
going on yeah
that's what happened with me like i
fought gilbert the first time right and
then in between me fighting him the
second time i broke my ankle
and i have a plate in my in my ankle
with nine screws
so every time i would kick if i kicked
with just like my
the front of my foot or if i hit your
elbow it would [ __ ] almost drop me
damn like anything like if you once you
hit the plate the plate hurts me more
than it hurts
i would think that it was yeah it
[ __ ] hurts you way more than it hurts
way more not even a little bit the also
too what you have to remember is it
takes away your flexibility like your
bones
they'll sometimes still bend a little
bit when the plates in now that plate is
like a fulcrum
so now the bone breaks over it so every
time i kick with it after i healed it up
and had the plate in
is every time i came with it like
another couple months after i would
break the the bone
jose plate i told my connor breaking his
leg no mine when i broke mine no no we
were talking about the fact
and when i fought gil the first time
that was like the well i went to the
well on the body kicks
after for the second fight i couldn't
kick because i broke my ankle in
training
so i have nine screws and a plate every
time i kick i'd break the bone above the
plate
oh good oh there's those kicks
and how'd you break it in training pedro
i was training with this kid named billy
evangelista and uh he came in he was the
guy that came in the last round
he was brian over here he gave me the
last round some punches off there so
oh we got a scramble and i went to st i
went to stand up and he
went to jump on my back and he didn't
make it all the way and so he pulled me
back or he fell on my ankle
coming backwards so his whole body fell
on the back of my ankles and you could
just probably
just slow motion it was like being
rolled up on like an offensive lineman
just [ __ ] got rolled up on it was
horrible man you've been paying
attention is it uh
so i've been walking
i missed i missed the first minute and a
half did he did did pedro get dropped
right now
no he's not making it yeah oh grass
right hand
i think it's 1-1 right now right i think
i think aldo's winning right now
there it is i'm telling you man his leg
kicks will make a difference in the game
yeah the whistle pig's good buffalo
trace buffalo
yeah i love buffalo trace but if you're
if the whistle pig
especially the 18 yeah it's good
[Music]
have
we go from having somebody's back to
being submitted like within a minute
yes that's gonna be a pretty rare
welcome to me yeah right
yeah cheese he chased that arm bar
though
if you know you got 10 seconds left like
go for it captured it
oh it hurt him good good oh good combo
god
he's [ __ ] getting fired with those
kicks man if you put the kicks in it
changes the whole game
that's it he's gonna run he won yeah he
won this fight
yeah he should have you put the kicks in
it changes his
if you if he throws his kick and then he
throws off the hands with the hands
right after he's [ __ ] money bro
you've had so good on the prelims
uh on espn you've had uh all decisions
one submission jessica penney one via
decision
i'm sorry just uh submission and then
this main card you've had all decisions
one submission so hopefully this is
finding out yeah hopefully this main
event
oh three jobs five rounds of gone
running
dude that would be a nightmare do you if
he
ufc is gonna be so sad if he wins yeah
that lay kick man i think he's going to
though
gods are i know he's just like gone
i i think derrick lewis is an athlete
bro i know he's a straight up athlete
like he's going to be smart he's going
to come out and be like look the only
way this guy beats me is if he hits me
with his [ __ ] right hand you're just
going to avoid it i know
why would you not if god if god ends up
on bottom at all
done i don't see how that's going to
done i mean
didn't have a [ __ ] prayer landing on
him i mean i like derek lewis he's
[ __ ] yeah i'm sure
dopey wins but i think with derek
lewistow is he explodes
whereas rosenstruck doesn't do that he
just stands there kind of like stalks
after you and just kind of helps you
come close i love his
awesome moment yeah who is against
volkov oh yeah yeah
he's like oh that's not possum no that's
not possible he was really [ __ ] hurt
really
he's he's a dog though derek lewis hey
didn't they make that uh
ref shave his beard no no he didn't come
in no he cut it no no
ufc makes them tuck it in yeah did
something happen did it tickle somebody
else you just don't like it
they don't want him they don't want him
to um look like there you go
no they don't want him to build a
character no they don't want people i
don't recognize him as a character
interesting because like big john's not
so big with his name big john mccarthy
yeah not too famous they don't want that
they want the fighters they they want
the ufc indeed
to get all the yeah you know that makes
sense
i mean it does when you're talking about
like where you're politicians
pedro no no so funny though those
considerations like hey hey buddy
yeah we want you to be dope as [ __ ] he
let me [ __ ] fight
the fight before when i seen you yeah
with one shoulder
just because he knew like i was still in
it yeah he's a great guy he knew my
shoulder was out
i fought fourth and fifth with one
shoulder yep but with one arm and he
he was like now i seen something in your
kid yeah he's stuck
and now he's like look where you are now
where i met you there's a place to eat
around here
we got pizza back there yeah we have
something starving from marijuana
okay just don't eat in the mic though
you know
yeah you got this yeah
yeah you won
if i saw the guy on the street i
wouldn't think he speaks portuguese
it's not bad bro yeah it's like uh you
have someone run your diet
yeah i have this guy named uh andy
ah he's good yeah who you used to tj or
no
no no no i just know him i went to
school there
cal state fullerton yeah
so he's got a good bro no
i just uh he's a big [ __ ] dude though
man
i have problems eating healthy yeah
yeah i yeah i have bad problems like i
yeah you like food okay yeah dude
mexican food every food i don't give a
[ __ ] what it is
a jack-in-the-box chick-fil-a like like
uh
if you look at me and you think like oh
that guy's a professional
athlete or a fighter like can you see
what i eat you call me out you're
i'm a fighter i don't give a [ __ ] i want
like i want to go in there and just [ __ ]
you
up yeah as long as i make the weight i
don't have to be do you hold them
accountable or do you guys give me
anything
i don't think you're better than me i i
was a bad influence in your life in
vegas
i was a bad influence in her life in
vegas in and out and [ __ ] all the time
oh
uh yeah
and then one [ __ ] came over once the
one dude then juan came over
after his fight dude yeah yeah one came
over after his fight and [ __ ] we're
like
eating these big ice cream sandwiches
and yeah they're like waffles with ice
cream
we had like things this big i was like
for sure
put it this way on the house i was still
watching what i was eating
and she was bringing me food from uh the
pi yeah i was
trying my best do they have good food
there no but healthy food
healthy food i don't any healthy food i
don't like the cafeteria ain't bad
no no it's any healthy food i don't like
oh gotcha yeah i like chicken and like
broccoli
yeah you give me some [ __ ] out of my
[ __ ] gold flavor
i'm easy to run to to junk food gotcha
like i was raised on it bro
yeah [ __ ] yeah me too i'm addicted to
sugar
[ __ ] top ramen and [ __ ] yeah mac
and cheese
yeah yeah mac and cheese frozen pizzas
tortillas
pizza rolls sugar everything
my son's gonna be [ __ ] when he goes to
school he don't know nothing about that
stuff dude
you don't like you're one of those dads
that like he's he's never seen candy or
some [ __ ]
he's had a little bit but not much away
from him yeah bro i mean
i'm on a
you know i mean like if i buy junk food
still like it's not like that much
it's like not really junk food you don't
have like fruit by the footage no [ __ ]
no
no way i've never seen that shot i've
got [ __ ] everywhere
what the [ __ ] is this here is this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
soda yeah soda what is dr pepper she's
amazing
dude yeah all right let me get one i
need your
teachings in my house my kids wake up
i'm like
bro there's ice cream it's tough
well like henry's get like cause hannah
and eve don't
they're like we got bananas let's go
this kid's fine
when he's 16 he's gonna freak the [ __ ]
out well yeah my kids wake up and
they're like hey
like i'm like [ __ ] yeah i get my kid
candy in the morning
i'm like there's uh there's pop rocks
yeah i bought a bunch of pop rocks
yeah and i'm like have some pop rocks
right now
it's like for real i was like yeah it's
breakfast dude how's it going
this is brilliant some milk pop rocks
you're good dude and then when i wake up
i cook them food you know but nice yeah
but the yeah i'm the breakfast guy bro
i wake up i i cook up i cook [ __ ]
i don't i don't wake up early it's just
like i like breakfast
it's like if i'm gonna cook something
it's gonna be breakfast like this
weekend it's always breakfast
quit playing uh all right kids if you
haven't aborted hairy balls it's time to
buzz light your woody with manscape the
official electric trimmer of the ufc
uh get your rocket ready like elon musk
for takeoff with the new lawnmower 4.0
kicker pubes another planet manscape is
taking off it's now available in not
only the usa but canada the uk across
europe australia south africa
singapore it's all over and all the
thick boys tonight get 20
off and free shipping with the code cfc
at manscape.com that's 20
manscape.com
uh we'll get 20 from free shipping
code cfc at manscape uh for clean
trinity and beyond your spaceballs well
thank you
i gotta get some manscape dude you can
take that one
don't shave your head though dude no
doubt your hair don't shave your head
again
no probably never do that again i gotta
give it to my brother bro he's like
16. he's in that age you know or like
can you impress the women
i'm not going to say nothing because my
mom's probably watching
your brother's good looking guy too oh
my brother my brother's a [ __ ]
dime he's a [ __ ] stud yeah he's stud
i've seen
bro that that [ __ ] he's yeah
yeah i'm he's a cool kid too he's cool
uh but he doesn't he stayed in vegas
with us the whole time the whole show
really he was there all [ __ ] seven
weeks
what would you not want to stay there
you bro he was having fun
he's a good kid man yeah he uh he's
trying to pursue acting actually good
for him yeah
you know like i thought i had good uh
like oh i have blue eyes but
you know when you have no blue eyes and
you still look good yeah that's how you
know you're a good-looking [ __ ]
yeah he's got that
yeah he's a good-looking kid yeah main
event
dear god derek lewis get this done
hey mark you're coming back dude how
much you done
what's up how about you down he's
gambling how much down the camera
because he can't get biceps eating
[ __ ] pizza you know what i mean like
he's doing that [ __ ] off camera
you gotta drink whiskey to get biceps
bro protein shake
protein cookie yeah
is that pizza any good from erwin good
[Laughter]
till tomorrow morning i'll leave at 5
a.m
i get up at like 10 o'clock 10 o'clock
nine o'clock
holy [ __ ] until your girl your girl's
getting up because that's like [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah i sleep in the guest room most
time oh wow
during fight camp i like that you're
honest about getting up at nine or ten
dude i'm gonna [ __ ] i
train late like my last prank my last
training i start at eight get done at 10
i get home [ __ ] can't sleep don't go
to sleep till like one or two o'clock
you know so i don't [ __ ] cause mark
wahlberg i got trained at four it's like
but you go to sleep at 6 00 p.m
yeah it's like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right yes his kids are like dad we've
seen you for half an hour
yeah yeah you're going to be right away
i wake up late as [ __ ]
yeah yeah i do not i wake up at 12.
i know i know that's why you look so
funny look at this guy yeah
depends late you're like two four five
okay
like five or if you're a professional
athlete nine ten hours
my training camps like yeah
like when that one like sometimes they
mix like our schedules or he's training
like when he was in camp and i'm in camp
yeah and they're like oh it's going to
be
like maybe the title is going to be a
problem and these guys are working out
by the time i hit my first session yeah
he's like yeah i'm already on my third
one i'm like
what the [ __ ] i'm like bro it's 12.
i woke up early today to get here like i
woke up at 10 30.
tj you're taking don yeah i got gone
gone's too much juvenile
here's the thing you only have 10 fights
yeah but dude he's an athlete
like you gotta think about like so look
i like derrick lewis's power i really do
and i like him as a [ __ ] just like
character
he's great he sells tickets he's [ __ ]
funny
but gone is the better fighter fighter
he's
smarter yeah like yeah if derek didn't
have that power he'd be super fun yeah
yeah
yeah but he goddamn yeah but he does but
he does this thing
he can finish in the late rounds too
yeah you know like yeah
like that vote clap fight he's getting
[ __ ] up and then just oh god
yeah the whole time but i just think
god's footwork's gonna be too much these
crowds can go nuts for
uh for [ __ ] deer clothes
[ __ ] stuff during the press
conference he's like
what do you think if you get beat by a
frenchman in front of your hometown
no that's why i have that thing because
yeah it fits big guys nice
fits up to six yeah the panamera does as
well yeah but the the lambos i don't
know how he does
no but there's one that looks like uh
different yeah i love the porsche's
monsters i drove a knife at land eleven
could do throw
or do you ever go to that little app
things like go-karts monsters
you ever gone to that place in carson
like up the world
yeah yeah yeah where you can just
[ __ ] it's a racetrack and you just
take porsches yeah
i know you can drive like gt3s and some
turbos but yeah it'd be fun
i pass it all the time and i [ __ ]
never go anywhere
supposed to be pretty dope your family's
still in colorado
yeah nice nice
come on derek lewis this fight's about
to be real boring
no i'm just giving me a [ __ ] i don't
know but don't jinx he loses i'm
pretty sure somebody's going based off
his walkout right now
do you think he looks nervous or ready
so definitely
he's always yeah yeah okay yeah but i
guarantee you he's nervous though yeah
he's fighting in houston bro
it's his hometown yeah i thought in
sacramento that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
ridiculous but i also got more pressure
huh
do am i my opponent switching 24 hour
notice oh
i was supposed to fight brow for the
second time after i beat him
and he didn't make weight so i fought
joe soto on 24 hours notice
oh [ __ ] yeah i was [ __ ] like deathly
afraid
i remember that i knew how good the guy
was i've trained with him he's a
bellator
champion no one knew who he was i took
that i took the final
24-hour notice like if i would have lost
to him i was ever like oh this guy's a
[ __ ] joke yeah you know
i was awesome for the title he survived
longer than expected right
from what he sort of survived longer
huh yeah that's what it was because
everyone was like dance [ __ ]
survived long like he was it was awesome
he gave me some good right hands for
the [ __ ] duralast battery yeah in a
situation like that
do they put pressure on you to accept
the fight like or do you is there any
part of you that's like i don't know
yeah i got this phone call
like look champ we need you to take this
bro yeah so that right up front we'll
take care of you
we need you to take this did they take
care of you no do you write
no i love them i've heard this story so
many times
it's [ __ ] great my favorite my
favorite is chris weidman
we took defying late notice stuff i
think it was i got one i got
zero dollar bonus 40 pounds he like
topped 40 pounds like eight days he's
like at least they're taking care of me
fights maya and he's like dude what the
[ __ ] they're like yeah
you're good dude yeah cause then dc
tells the story where he lost to jon
jones and they sent him like a million
dollar check or something
do you know that story yeah i've heard
that story i've heard it but happened to
shane collins i think he's making it up
i don't i don't know that's the case i
[ __ ] get my ass
interesting round number you came up
with you would but i mean if you think
about it
say that now but you wouldn't argue
about it they've taken care of beyond
you wouldn't do it like he's got so many
gigs doing you think so
obviously they like him oh yeah yeah
he's too prideful bro [ __ ] yeah
then if you win it's worth more than a
million for sure you know what i mean no
not my next one i'm saying like a fight
like a fight ever
if they're willing to pay you a million
dollars to lose it's worth
five times and that's fine you know yeah
no dude i've been fighting for a while
now you have to get a million-dollar
paycheck
well you beat volkanovsky you're gonna
not this time but that's what you said
but if they were like hey bro
[ __ ] no no no no no [ __ ] that for a
million and then i can still keep
stay at the top like [ __ ] it no way
did you go practice my acting you know
yeah yeah you got to get your ass kicked
in the movie all right let me do it for
real
that's right he's a real method actor
damn dance lost some weight
yeah he has right i was thinking the
same thing or he's wearing a triple xl
shirt
since they're just hanging off and spanx
derek's lost weight too
yeah i like he's like no you won't he's
got he's got 20 pounds to make it
265 though yeah because he's still
crazy this guy there's been a couple
guys that had to cut 65.
crazy why would you get a tattoo like
that on your chest which one
[ __ ] you talking about his god smack
that dude
bring up the godsmack logo are you doing
i can get behind this right here i get
behind this dude that's a deep cut
to god smack this some of this one right
here what is this that's a tattoo that's
got smack that's almost as bad as the
[ __ ] dick in the chest from
car what's not car with the [ __ ]
hammer the sword jesus
do you know that band what was their key
song
chin they had some slappers back in the
day moon baby was one of them
i don't you would know how much baby
he knew it right away you said gossip
was there to either moon
got you you had it ah
stand alone real that's cool keep away
unforgettable bullet proof
what's this what's this tattoo say knock
out what
minus 350 at heavyweight somebody's
always got to go
i didn't know
know aside from being like america
versus france this is also like a
light-skinned dark-skinned war
i'm just like that's right that's right
in the race
oh [ __ ] it took that part i think i just
know a lot of people
it is interesting he used to train with
i realized you're just here to stir the
pot
you're really here just to stir the
[ __ ] trolls i
love it i love it [ __ ]
it come on there no
small person in the back right corner is
that who's that girl
that's a girl he's a girl but i think
that's just one of his trainers
oh yeah female trainer [ __ ] no strength
and conditioning i think oh
yeah strength and conditioning yeah i
can see it oh jack
like cool awesome i mean he possesses
knockout power so she's doing something
right
this guy come on dick
i do i do love him i want him to win
just because boxing
is terrible but yeah i just want to
[ __ ]
come on i would what size glove do you
think he had to make for him size 5x i i
don't think his hands are that big he's
not like francis or shin cartoons
yeah right it was a [ __ ] seven eggs
he's my wrestling coach in colorado and
we were doing some fishing on the lake
and we were drinking beer hanging out on
his boat
and uh like hey shane you need a beer
he's like no i got one
he's got it in his hand like this looks
like you can't see it because it's
holding like this it looks like those
mini coats
you can't see his beard he's like no i
got a bomb
oh [ __ ] they did the same [ __ ] with uh
remember the documentary they did on
audrey the giant yeah yeah and he was
like
he looks like he has one of those 22
ounce [ __ ]
these couples the giant though yeah
shane the almost a giant come on derek
here we go i i bet he's just gonna blitz
his ass early on
he's gonna sit back and get he's loading
up that right he's i think he's just sit
back though
yeah and he said he's gonna sit down he
fight interviews that's what he said
he's not coming after him he's not going
around you can kind of come after gone
though because he doesn't really knock
dude
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he threw a head kick
damn he got his foot up there too i was
about to say that that was one of those
that's like one of the craziest things
i've ever seen was dc throw a [ __ ]
head kick right you see a guy that looks
like kung fu panda
yeah just throwing [ __ ] head kicks
and derek luke just threw one
i love this champion i love it man i
love it
i can't on see that got smack tattoo on
god's chest
it is tragic the tattoo down his spine
reminds me of the angelina jolie tattoo
on her back
dude that's the least of my [ __ ] stop
turning me on dude
oh [ __ ] come on d
tomb raider yeah his footwork is filthy
dude
nah he's gonna let's catch him yeah
yeah god's gonna get a little too cocky
and no way bro i don't don
is kind of i think they're
no hands are down he's already kind of
like oh okay you're not doing anything
thank you guys you're not seeing any of
derrick lewis's [ __ ] fights
you know do [ __ ] for [ __ ] 14 minutes
it just knocks you out
i wouldn't i wouldn't mind if uh derek
did a blast double on his ass either oh
that'd be funny
he doesn't like it i'm telling you right
now if if something happens and derek
lewis stands on the top he's gonna knock
him out agree he'll ground
probably the best in the game yeah it's
good has that like bigger version of
fedor
yeah i think he has the most knockouts
via ground power oh doubt it
come on here's the thing guys we can get
five rounds of this that's what i'm
saying
moose doesn't knock him out you're
getting this for a five [ __ ] rounds
oh like we
got down the controllers he just pulled
it john jones turned his back and ran
[ __ ] on his bike oh
[ __ ] i'm pretty sure this week you're
gonna get though
i don't know tj oh i think i think in
the last minute of every round i think
derek looks gonna explode
he's gonna be like all right i'm good
[ __ ]
come back john's just piecing them up
right now
not much going on nothing nothing's
really general he's only landed one
thing if i'm gained and i'm a smart
[ __ ] fighter stick his leg
[Music]
[Laughter]
he don't want to wrestle no who wants to
wrestle no one
no one wants to [ __ ] wrestle him i
know how to wrestle i don't want to
wrestle yeah
i [ __ ] hate it especially it would be
interesting if john jones fought as you
get older it's worse
they do hurt it's horrible she hurts
it's a lot of energy
it's like [ __ ] wrestling aspect
that's what goes through your mind right
when you don't get it you're like [ __ ]
you're like
oh you killed him in the nuts it would
be interesting if john fought a
heavyweight to see him and gone go at it
because john can match him
technique-wise yeah yeah and he's in his
reach
yeah my balls but outside john nobody's
gonna [ __ ] with him
oh yeah clip the dick just got the tip
but dude all you got was the tip every
time i've been kicked in the balls it
should never hurt
it doesn't what do you wear i wear a
steel cup
i wear like the [ __ ] big five one
i just
i just look at my chances of really
getting hit
it only takes one time [ __ ] that from
the last cup i have
no idea that's why my ass don't surf man
it only takes one time for a shark to
get you
oh no right i'm like [ __ ] i want to
learn how to surf
every time i'm always like [ __ ]
i've been out there a couple of times
i'm like [ __ ] this is horrible just i
feel paranoid the whole time i was out
there
looking around oh
look at him running look at him running
smiling why are you running dog
come on let's go let's fight he's
smarter get him derek
he ain't no he's kind of playing the
game though a little bit he's gonna be
playing with fighters you can get caught
up ufc ufc man that they can
god please lose please lose i mean
derrick
that's the closest come to landing when
he turned his back
there's gonna be like he's okay
body is the easiest thing to go on
derrick right
yeah he took remember he got hurt a lot
from volkov yeah with the
to the body yep a little tokyo oh
she brought left kick after oh god doug
it's not looking good no it's looking
was like that's a punch dog yeah it's
not looking good for d
no all right not good not my eye damn
yeah i think it was the yeah boom we
have [ __ ] right
when you're like training and the
[ __ ] glove really touches you and
you're like mother screams
yeah hardly touches you
yeah i really get punched like full on
then like just rather get hit full-on
like sometimes like i hit like a little
light touch and like
i'm like [ __ ] it's like a paper
cut right yeah
it just feels weird nothing worse than
just that it feels like the eyes of the
glove across like your eyelid
it's [ __ ] horrible yeah or if you
catch the laces at all
like the laces on the other side you
round for gone huh yeah
yeah yeah one zero but i feel like uh
well at least like jericho
is showing up derrick lewis
he's fighting in [ __ ] houston he's
fighting for the title
yep he said he worked out more he's
never worked out his entire life like
people don't do that unless you're
nervous yeah you're right you know
like i'm gonna go work out way more than
i've ever worked on my life until
i'm nervous yep you know yep come on d
bro you've been talking up game i know
well this is why he's [ __ ] good
i just figured in the hometown dick
lewis throw caution in the wind maybe
land something
he'll get there you got five rounds i
don't know dude in the second round
the longer it goes the least chances
yeah but honestly like the way i looked
at it right now uh
when you look at him in the corner derek
wasn't breathing yeah he you that's a
good point he wasn't breathing that hard
he was just like
well good then [ __ ] and the other guy
was like
it's just oh he needs to stop those kids
i love it though oh that worked though
what were you saying though where was it
what were you saying to stop the kids
i'm saying that headquarters yeah it's
because god's too talented
it's not going to work on this guy watch
that [ __ ] come on watch them
gonna be amazing
so no matter who wins this francis is
gonna have to fight the winner
that's what's kind of dope about intern
belts there's no you have no choice dude
you're gonna have to fight the guy yeah
what's the deal with francis why he goes
down the problem with the contract yeah
he has one fight left on his contract he
wants
he wants more money to fight jones yeah
what's your own blame makes the [ __ ]
bad
man on the planet yeah makes sense
[ __ ]
i like the ufc's like we're not playing
john or francis so it's like you guys
wanna
yeah because they already got the deal
with espn oh
what was that come on d
yeah i hear a lot about that about like
the negotiating power that they have
with these fighters
we don't need to sell pay-per-views they
have oh oh oh they have the power
because of the espn deal
yeah that basically took all the they
don't have stars yeah they don't need
stars anymore
yeah they could just filled you [ __ ] and
then it doesn't matter they still get
paid yeah they don't care
yeah once that deal got signed it just
took all the bargaining rights away from
the fighters yeah
he's gotta win yes yeah come on you
gotta [ __ ] win bro that's a good body
but that's an awesome
it's not just the ufc it's everything
you if you're scared if you don't win
you're not gonna get paid yeah yeah yeah
i mean that's i've said that for years
man winning solves everything just keep
winning
and you guys guys are there there's guys
that can lose and keep getting paid but
connor you're not one of those guys yeah
yeah just just
nick you know yeah i wasn't afraid to
see apollo cost it was like i'm
not fighting because i'm not getting
paid enough and then he gets a hair
transplant
yeah he's also a guy that the ufc was
like cool man
right right yeah he overestimates his
value is like there's very few guys who
can pull that your
potential to be a star but you just got
your ass beat
man if we get four more rounds this i'll
be pissed
i'm telling you uh it only takes a split
yeah he's too good
heavy weights man it's only take a split
second do you think it's any different
with francis
he does francis no i think francis
pieces him up
france is a little more dangerous
because he's explosive he's good
too he's more explosive but i still
think game beats him dude
yeah i do yeah he's a better average
what you're saying though is you're
single you're saying that again you're
saying that gone could beat
stipe no yeah see there you go that's
but he beats francis yeah but ain't
gonna beat nobody foreign
i don't think anybody beats god i could
be honest if he fights like this
i think stephen beats him god this would
be the worst thought
you could have as a champion gosh
landing right heavily and this way he's
gonna fight yeah i am not watching he's
grinding wrestling pictures no you don't
get it
ufc does not want a french guy as a
champion that fights like this
i'm sure they i kind of think they do
they want to go to france money they
don't
no yeah they want houston they can't
sell this
they want d lewis to knock him out and
fight francis balls are hot yeah yeah
i mean like like derek's markable yeah
he is he's how do you describe his style
josh
who's gone yeah he's well-rounded man
he's probably
he's probably the most well-rounded
heavyweights he's the best athlete in
the division
i don't think john's a better athlete
than god uh you know john
john ran a 4-9 in the 40s sir what does
that mean
i'm just bonded or john john okay i'm
just saying like athletics do you think
gone can run faster than that i think i
think brendan did like a four six
correct but well i'm really running four
five three
four six yeah i'm holding five pounds no
big deal but i'm just
that's actually really [ __ ] fast bro
had a cappuccino with buffalo bills
anyways
so but i'm just saying that's actually
really [ __ ] fast
i'm just saying like athletically
explosive i think god's more explosive
like
john don't have knockout power i agree
you're talking okay so who's the better
athlete though is what you're saying
but john's the better fighter like just
because you're
a good athlete doesn't mean you're great
so wait are we judging after being
the best athlete because you can run a
40 faster and you can do more pull-ups
jump is that where you're at faster more
explosive better times other sports
faster i think especially at heavyweight
faster than john i don't know man
i think i think we underestimated john
right now
i think john's a better fighter yeah and
that includes like the creativity that
creativity wrestling yeah how he mixes
it up
yeah his iq is fine he's not saying like
his single [ __ ] like the way he chooses
single shots like a single strike versus
a single stick and like
like you just don't know what's coming
he's the highest iq in the ufc i think
john does best fight iq in the game no
yeah i mean yeah i would have said it
could be but we had a straight up just
this was
his iq iq the [ __ ] i take you down
yeah that's that's honest that's the
best iq he never changed
most fighters would want to change their
iq too that's all you can do though
for fans think about john he has to
wrestle yeah strike hit he has to figure
the guy out
and then after that first round john
usually takes over yeah
i thought it was like i'm gonna take you
down if you're saying
here's the thing it's hard for me to
judge that based off because
jon jones we don't know when he can box
trump he's both there's both his
brothers in the nfl
i'm sure they can jump high i'm sure
they can run faster and i'm sure
they're better athletes the apple didn't
fall far from the tree yeah
so if he was this good of an athlete why
is he not in the nfl
why is he not doing all those other
things he's from france dude
that's so funny you know like friendship
like football
yeah he's a giant dude in france man
that's what he decided to do
oh man but yes john would be the better
fighter so what are you saying about
french people
is that what we're doing they're not
interested they're generally not tough
you know
yeah you know what most koreans are not
sticks too there's some big [ __ ]
koreans
oh yes most koreans are pronounced 16.
yeah they're not no no
yeah ginger the biggest group did you
did you watch do you listen to rogan's
last show with that uh
jaomi park yes good god
i saw the highlights i was like oh i
don't want to cut my [ __ ] throat oh
my gosh
man i just saw some of the clips about
people eating kids or something oh my
god testing's falling out of them no i
don't know i don't know he doesn't fall
out of her body and like still begging
for
i love north korea oh my gosh that's one
of my favorites
i love learning about north korea i'm
all sad
i'm all about it man i'm
podcast at least four times oh you're a
psychopath i [ __ ] love it man i'm
like this is
crazy to think what's my weird obsession
just to think of like
all the [ __ ] that's going on there and
people like oh wow
her mom said that she was not telling
the truth her mom's probably afraid for
her life
yeah homeboy just killed his [ __ ]
brother and his uncle yeah for power
that stuff's too dark man jesus man
imagine if you're korean
oh god and was it was it three hours of
her talking about that
yeah stressing three and a half almost
like three twenty set
damn it's like watching schindler's list
every day dude yeah i'm out
i thought you were saying like the thing
about her though watching her
like talk about it is she's she's pretty
hot so yeah she is attractive yeah
which helps but i mean looks aren't
everything i was listening to the car so
i didn't really get to see it but
no oh there goes that elbow oh if he
ends up on the bottom
if he ends up on bottom ah come on there
killer
leg
that's a good point
he tried against matriarch he got
knocked out oh oh foot sweep
almost got him he needs to [ __ ] just
go yes you're going to lose
yeah you're going to sit back and he's
weird he's going to be like too worried
yeah too [ __ ] nervous
he ain't going to finish houston houston
seconds before you judge what's going to
happen
i guarantee you going this round this
team's like dude you got to get going
here
we got paul in the front what's the
worst can happen you just [ __ ] go you
get knocked out lately at least you're
going to lose watching oh he's trying
he's kind of trying
yeah that one hurt the difference in
that kick versus
the first round where he was just kind
of tapping him yeah i think it's gonna
affect that kid
you noticed god hasn't been [ __ ] whoa
oh [ __ ] god
it's around trouble it's a rap it's a
wrap ten
he gave up yeah he's not fighting back
back throw back
six he's fight back now all right there
we go like your best chances to fight
back
but sometimes this one oh well slick
that was slick
yeah and god hasn't really been [ __ ]
touched dude
at all get him dick oh i even touch it
all
right what is easy [ __ ] close to it
what do you think it's a wrap here or no
not yet it's close
very close but sometimes derek a land
when what was that mouthpiece
oh my god that was slick
oh that hit him in the face see but this
is when derek knocks out when you're
trained like this he's all tired
yeah oh yeah i'm telling you that
he's going to stop it they're going down
yeah he did he wanted out well that's a
shame
damn it son tj did you bet
no [ __ ] no no he's like no you should
have yeah he called it i know
are you guys allowed to bet on the ufc
fights yeah you're right i don't even
know
yeah you can't get better yourself i
don't think you've been understanding
you're better than yourself and you can
bet other people's fights yeah
you can better yourself you can't just
bet your opponent's gonna win
yeah you can bet on yourself yeah
because that one that one kid bound
himself
met his whole person and lost everything
he lost split decision to it yeah [ __ ]
dude i [ __ ] put up and then
no i'm saying like i keep talking about
that though oh yeah justin james
i'm saying like has no regrets i don't
mean it like that
[ __ ] yeah it's like a come up
yeah he bet 25k on himself that was just
yeah
that's a bummer god derrick lewis looked
really really bad
he didn't do nothing and then he looked
like you're nervous yeah
he was the hometown he's too nervous
dude too much pressure
like that pressure you can't [ __ ]
handle sometimes you know like
it's so much easier when there's not
that much light on you but when there's
that much [ __ ] light
championship [ __ ] fights dealing with
the [ __ ] media
fighting your hometown here's the thing
donald donald francis man that god
doesn't get [ __ ] hit dude yeah
yeah so they're going to be stipe and
jon jones
well done no yeah they got to pay john
so okay so if they don't get it done i
hope they get it done i like to see god
and jon jones that's a fight that
[ __ ] t-shirt feels like a rash card
oh my god snug [ __ ] medium super snug
so that happens it'll be gone jones
no next is gone francis yeah for sure i
just wanted to make the pun
videos but but do you know what the
thing is is francis doesn't sign that
contract that they're asking you're
gonna get john jones i bet
what do you think the president is gonna
look like now with him like this yeah
can you do what do you do with gun gone
sepe
gone stipe fight for the interim because
he see god's gonna already be the
interim champ right now
if john jones wants it if france if yeah
john johnson
so then cb automatically gets his title
shot right which is what he wants yeah
which is what he wants
because he was the interview started
going to one championship or something
just like yeah you know the ufc contract
worked
yeah but he the thing is he was on his
last fight for his contract it sends you
two more fights but every time you fight
for the title
if you're the champ every time you
defend your title it sends you two more
fights that's dirty
yeah i think it's a bell tour thing i
don't think it's a no you have to see it
for sure hundred percent are you mixing
up here we're gonna have five champions
in new york
yeah i don't know yeah you're right i
don't know if you're extending your your
contract extends every time you
defend your title for two fights yeah
it's in your is there a dilla shark
claws
that shirt is so tight down to your
point right that shirt is
well it's a [ __ ] shirt yeah it's
cutting off his back
dc used to be heavyweight this guy's big
he's [ __ ] he's tall
yeah yeah but this ain't that big either
is he calling anybody out
is anybody listening in here he's
listening is he calling you
he's just talking bad english
you probably can't show the volume on
here no no so i have to guess
yeah like we had cody garbrandt on sugar
shawn called him out yeah and i was like
man can you imagine
sean called you out they were like
bullshitting that's all i was like dude
i think it's a bad fight for cody
sugar's athletic yeah i really do i
think it's a bad fight
but it's not happening because cody's
fighting uh it's good i do cody's small
man cody's fight yeah
yeah yeah yeah his last fight he walked
into the cage 142 pounds
yep yes you told me you weighed in 136
and walking 142 like yeah
i thought 125s and walked in 152. yep
yeah
like yeah that's wild yeah i think they
they uh
confirmed he's fighting france i think
yeah they did which is a tough fight
dude
yeah that's what i but that was my whole
point like dude fight sugar
again tough fight but everybody knows
sugar yeah france a lot more than one
you can fight
a lot more to win yeah dude yeah but
everybody knows sugar
yeah no well is that it kids
has he called anybody out nothing he's
not my friend him and france is our
friend so i doubt he talks [ __ ]
anything casey taking his team he's
snaking this team
yeah that whole time the whole time
right i'll say the same [ __ ]
that's awesome i'll tell you you could
give gon fritz in his heyday it would be
dc
yeah cause he couldn't beat him down
yeah i think he beat him now
he beat him yeah built built like a
[ __ ] armadillo
i think you should be mounted on the
couch built like an armadillo
hey bro what's going on with your suits
like bro i can't wear a tie anymore
next too i get my neck's too big i can't
wear it anymore
none of my shirts [ __ ] hate me i
can't button the top button
so hard it's so great there's no oh dc
would break him i
don't think right now dc needs a eight
month training dc's 44 years
43 years old four months 42 20
yeah that's just too much he'd be
stylish
is interesting though as you're saying
that's a good thing that's that that
gives you
exactly what he wants he can fight for
the title next he wants that
fight if that make you the interim
champion you're guaranteed to be next
until francis or jon jones i think he
really wants that john jones fight
because that fight will make him more
money than he's made in all of his other
fights steve
john's offense yeah i think
and he's not having it right they're
friends that's the other problem they're
friends
dc trying to stand up for francis is
that like yeah that's the fight like
let's do it pretty much well it's got to
be the fight right you're the inner
choice yeah you have to fight the
champions although francis with that
contract
francophones stick together i mean
if you're the interim champion you fight
the champion there's no other choice
well you sound like there was another
i can't remember whether yeah you know
that one in our championship i'm the
fake champion you know
he had to defend our title a couple
times you can defend your internal
championship your fake championship
no but i'm gonna defend my fake
championship
there was another weight class i can't
remember who it was but they had they
had the interim
yeah someone it was i think it was
highway yeah yeah there was an interim
champion
the interim championship is a [ __ ]
joke though right i mean let's be honest
like
you have to fight the champion though
true well not everyone's been a multiple
what happens if the champion never comes
back what happens
[ __ ] tyson fury well then you're the
champion correct
you're not the interim no more yeah i
get what you're saying but like like if
you're the interim champion you're kind
of like
it's like saying like i think the
internet fake champion the interim used
to have some value to it now they do it
and i feel over time it lost its value
yeah
yeah because i'll throw it into seller
yeah well now they do it to press the
you know
yeah oh it's selling reviews they'll
fight this guy yeah the only way they'll
know where to get the comments
i'll pay for it yeah all right is that
it kids
that's it daddy to thank you thank you
holding the fort down i've always wanted
to say chin to pull that up for me
please
good [ __ ] appreciate that i never
want to be that guy bring that [ __ ] up
hold up it's [ __ ] great well we love
you guys what do we got for you i'm in
north carolina august 19th through 21st
north carolina
and then end of the month i'm at la
jolla comedy store
was that august 26 28 that's a thursday
friday
saturday la jolla california tommy store
san jose's september 9th through 11th
take it to fatkz.com or thickboy.com
uh thank you guys for doing this man
love you guys september 9th yes question
san jose oh that's right you'll be let's
go that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] good i've got some
friends going too from the barrier yeah
oh yeah you're from there too that's
[ __ ] next fight companion calves
fighting
september 17th is uh bellator and
strikeforce or sorry bellator in san
jose also oh damn so i think big john
will be in town when you're doing your
show oh that'd be fun
uh next uh fight campaign will be before
the 29th jake paul woodley have a great
lineup all right love you guys thanks
for watching
not the best card
you